good morning everybody morning uh
welcome to the second
Yale International Coral Festival I'm so
excited to see all of you here and so
excited for everything that this week
has in store for us we're looking
forward to Fantastic concerts from all
of our visiting choirs uh Coro Entre
voses from Cuba the Jerusalem Youth
Chorus vas Nord from Sweden and the
National University of Singapore uh
choir as well as concerts by the Y Coral
artist and Yale alumni chorus and we're
also very excited excited for all that
will transpire in a Innovative new Coral
conducting course called Coral uh called
conducting
21c uh organized by the Eric Ericson
International Coral Center in Stockholm
it's the first time this class has taken
place outside of Sweden first time in
North America uh there are many many
people uh who have helped to make this
Festival possible and we're going to be
thanking them in various ways throughout
the week uh but right now I just want to
acknowledge a few uh people who have
helped to make today's Symposium
possible uh first of all Tim sharp
executive director of the American coral
director's Association and Michael
Anderson uh president of the
International Federation for Coral music
for all of their support of this
Symposium uh and also my friends
Francisco Nunes and Andre de quatros for
serving as special Symposium advisers uh
we'll hear today from four panels
comprised of leaders in the coral field
and related fields the primary question
they'll examine is if we believe that
group singing has the power to change
lives for the better how do we harness
this power in an intentional way in our
day-to-day work each panel will explore
this question from a different angle uh
exploring the human impact of singing
what happens in rehearsal and
performance expanding our reach and
crafting performance joining me to
introduce the members of our first panel
exploring the human impact of singing is
Stephanie tubiolo a graduate student in
our Coral conducting program at Yale uh
who as research fellow has also been
helping with the organization of today's
Symposium as well as this week's
conducting 21 master class so welcome
and I'll turn things over to
[Music]
Stephanie Andre de quadros is music
director and conductor of the monado
State University choir of Indonesia and
the artistic director of conducting 21c
he is also a professor of Music at
Boston University and holds affiliate
faculty positions in the African studies
Center center for the study of Asia
Institute for the study of Muslim
societies and civilizations and the
prison education program at Boston
University Julianne paralisi is a music
therapist Pioneer and passionate Coral
singer she is the founder of music
therapy with out borders an organization
that specializes in leading
international service projects around
the globe bringing music therapy
services to locations that would not
otherwise have access to them thus
expanding the reach of the field while
offering opportunities for students and
professionals to broaden their
Multicultural
competency margarit Brooks joined the
yel faculty in 1985 as chair of the
coral conducting program at the school
of music and director of coral music at
at The Institute of Sacred Music she has
served on the faculties of Smith and
Amherst colleges and was director of
coral music at the State University of
New York at
Stonybrook Dr Steven demerist is a
professor of music education at
Northwestern University where he teaches
graduate and undergraduate courses in
Coral music methods music cognition
research methods and philosophy his
research interests include the cognitive
neurological and social Foundation of
inaccurate singing the cultural
Neuroscience of music and sight singing
[Applause]
pedagogy good morning
morning as Stephanie said I'm Julianne
and I'm a board certified music
therapist therapist so I am privileged
every single day to witness personal
Transformations that come about by using
music and intentional and clinical ways
with people of all ages and
abilities it is my personal mission and
passion in life to help people um
experience connection growth
transformation Joy all through engaging
in the creative and expressive Arts this
morning we thought thought we'd kick off
the day by enjoying a little creative
musical experience together to get our
minds and bodies woken up and ready to
go ready to listen so you
ready I would like to invite you to
stand
up okay I'm going to split the room up
into a couple chunks uh let's
see there mayy
that's grou one and we got here to maybe
there group
two and
then can I see group
one good group
two good we might need a couple more
group three so hand
down
sweet all
right started group
[Music]
one
la
[Music]
sh
ch
[Music]
do
everybody one more time
thank
[Applause]
you oh see Sor
soror you want me to
goad
is it possible for us to get the lights
uh
right don't they look happy
um my charge today uh in the next 12
minutes is to quickly review uh some of
the research on singing wellbeing and
what uh it what it really tells us in
doesn't tell us about what's going on um
obviously we're here today uh in part
because our belief in the power of
singing and also I think for for all of
us uh the personal experience of how
singing changed our lives um what we
might want to remember is that we're
maybe not
typical uh that in many ways I
understand I heard the laughter uh but
uh National surveys suggest that 34% of
adolescence continue in music past
Elementary School and of those 34% 177%
of them which yay for us is the largest
percent continue in singing um that
number goes down as they reach high
school graduation so if we want to make
claims about how what engaging in
singing does for everybody then we have
to take a scientific approach to
studying it and we have to look at
people who aren't already committed to
singing as a life choice and that's the
framework for my talk today my uh my own
work is in um inaccurate singing and uh
helping both children and adults who
have difficulty matching pitch and also
looking at some of the psychological and
social consequences of being labeled a
poor singer so um that's kind of my
context uh that I'm coming to this from
but more recently just in this last year
uh I've gotten engaged in studies
looking at the effects of singing with
um aphasic patients and also Alzheimer's
patients and those two studies are
starting next year so I'm getting up to
speed in this literature uh and want to
share that with you so when we think of
singing and well-being this is mostly
what we
see choir singing may be good for your
heart choir singing improves health and
work environment and Time Magazine like
a drug advertisement group singing has
been scientifically proven to lower
stress relieve anxiety and Elevate
endorphins by now okay so um having
recently experienced uh a study of mine
getting published and then going through
the media reinterpretation process I'm
sympathetic to the authors of these
studies that that their work is being uh
presented perhaps a little bit too uh uh
over the top uh with results but that's
what you need in a headline um when I
see a headline like this what I ask
myself are two things one okay I want to
read the study it's the first question I
ask and secondly what was their
methodology and research in this area
has used three main methodologies the
first qualitative investigation this is
dealing with in-depth study of a small
group or sometimes a uh even one or two
individuals and their experience with
singing surveys and questionnaires these
are done as self-report measures how
much people like singing uh and and what
they perceive their quality of life to
be so it's people telling you about
their life experience uh but in a little
bit more systematic and large sample way
and finally experimental and for um
those of us engaged in the research
process the benefit of an experiment
approach if you want to say that singing
group singing causes X whatever X might
be um you really have to be engaged in
experimental research um that's really
the only way to to demonstrate that on
any kind of scale so I'm going to go
through quickly um these three types of
research and what we what we know just
I'm just going to do a sampling of
studies and you have some of them in
your
bibliography um qualitative
investigations I'm going to focus on two
that were done by Bailey and Davidson
looking at participants in a homeless
choir
and uh they only sampled a small group
of the participants from these choirs
the participants reported that singing
reduced depression and created a
positive emotional experience that it it
actually helped them relax but also
created energy they felt more energetic
after participating in the choir and
perhaps most importantly for this
population um increased their mental
focus uh got kind of got their mind off
of their problems a little bit and
increased their sense of self-worth
particularly the performance aspect of
it the important thing to remember about
this kind of research is the goal of
This research is not to generalize
beyond the people that were studied so
we cannot say from this research that
all homeless people will benefit from
singing in a choir for example so that's
one of the things to keep in mind it
doesn't mean the research isn't
important and gives us some insights
into what might be possible benefits of
singing for these populations but this
research itself can't go beyond um who
they
study the next area surveys and
questionnaires um I I picked two uh
really nice surveys one is a Clifton
Hancock's large study with choirs from
three different countries um they asked
them to report on uh how much uh they
enjoyed singing what a benefit they
thought it was and also take the World
Health Organization brief questionnaire
on psychological well-being which is a
great measure it's one of the few
measures we have that kind of tries to
standardize the notion of well-being in
a way that that we can have some
confidence in what people say they found
um
that there was a small correlation
between singing and psychological
well-being only for the women in their
sample which were the majority of their
sample um not for the men um they did
however have some qualitative findings
from the uh long answer portion that
were U more positive particularly a
weird group people who scored low on the
psychological well-being but high on the
singing enjoyment which kind of goes
against their correlation but actually
for those people singing was to them
seen as more important in helping them
deal with what they were going through
um Johnson's study was with 117 older
community choir members in Finland where
they have a lot of senior
activities um they reported greater
benefits of choir saying they had higher
quality of life they also used the World
Health Organization questionnaire had
higher quality of life both in the
psychological and I think really
importantly for this population the
social uh area of the questionnaire um
they also reported fewer symptoms of
depression and greater satisfaction with
their health now one of the limitations
here and we we'll get to this a minute
is they only surveyed people who had
chosen all both of these studies people
had chosen singing as an
activity so it's kind of important just
to remember based on what I said at the
beginning finally I want to spend a
little time with
experimental we've read a lot of
interpretation about particularly the
first group physiological changes the
big three for physiological changes
cortisol immunoglobulin a and oxytocin
need I say more probably uh
cortisol cortisol is connected with
stress so low cortisol good high
cortisol bad um and what this research
found some of it it it they've had real
difficulty replicating the findings of
This research which is always an issue
with experimental research but what they
found in general um cortisol tends to go
down for amateur singers participating
in a singing activity goes up for
everybody in a performance which is good
we want them to be right a little bit
more uh on top of things but um but it
it it does go down for amateur singers
in rehearsal not for professional
singers They're working after all uh
right um imunoglobulin a is a immune
system response is measured through the
saliva and if it goes up it's good means
your immune system is working better two
studies found increases after sing so
that's good and oxytocin is a kind of a
feel-good bonding uh hormone and uh the
grape uh study found that oxytocin
increased in both amateur and
professional singers but uh more so for
the amateurs and the and the
professionals did not report feeling
better they just uh report they just had
an actual physical change so um going
quickly the next three groups of studies
what I like about the next three groups
is at least one of the studies in these
groups used um a control condition which
is really important experimental
research there's two things in
experimental research random assignment
and an equivalent or some sort of
control condition and all three studies
use that the Cohen randomly assigned
seniors to either a singing group or a
typical senior activity found greater
overall health fewer doctor visits less
medication use fewer Falls less
loneliness better morale and more
activities for the music group so that's
good that's really good and and they
were randomly assigned to singing versus
the other activities um the uh Bonilla
uh did pulmonary benefits of a group of
patients who had pulmonary distress and
found strong s benefits for singing The
Foo study this is a a student a PhD
student in nursing at Washington that I
supervised I was part of her
dissertation she actually did a pilot
study with um seniors in regular um
Assisted Living Andor Independent Living
three groups um she found pulmonary
benefits for a group singing activity
and cognitive benefits they were better
at word fluency of the group that
participated in singing so there's some
real potential I think in both of these
studies suggests real potential working
with seniors and singing I want wanted
to throw these in because it's important
for us to realize that these don't often
get pressed Davidson did a really nice
study with seniors uh and found no
difference in any of the things they
were predicting with singing it's
important to realize that and David or
Valentine and Evans found that that solo
singing and group singing improved um uh
their uh positive attitude and and that
sort of thing but they found that
swimming was better than than both I am
so just I'm just saying okay I don't
mean to be Debbie Downer here but I'm
just trying to give us a picture of
what's going
on so some of the limitations of these
studies that we need to keep in mind one
um selection uh a lot of the studies
measure people who've already selected
to be inquire so it's like asking
somebody do you enjoy this activity that
you've chosen to spend extra time doing
um we might get the answer yes in a lot
of cases for that um a lack of
comparison to non- singers in some of
the survey studies it would be nice to
have matched group of people who are
similar in age lifestyle Etc but don't
sing to find out if the quality of life
is really different I suspect it might
be but we need to know um methods lots
of self-report so um some of that's
necessary like quality of life um with
most people you have to ask them um but
it's important to try to get a a better
sense of changes that people might not
be aware of um lack of randomization we
talked about that and lack of meaningful
control so the the gold standard for a
clinical trial is a randomized control
trial where the control condition has a
lot of the features of the experimental
condition but not the crucial feature
and we're in the infancy of doing that
kind of research but I think the
potential is there and I think that's
where we're headed we're seeing an
uptick and experimental work and I think
that's going to be positive for us um in
terms of really learning what's going on
so in
summary choir members believe that
singing contributes to their well-being
and those who like choir that is those
who believe in those positive benefits
report a higher quality of life so it's
working for them um really really well
the physical evidence for benefits is
weak that is hormone changes and things
like that but always positive okay so we
haven't found negative effects of
singing for physiological measures which
I think is really important and the
physiological benefits are strongest for
um older
singers uh this next area I think is is
the most potential we have with older
adults potential to reduce depression
increased sociability and quality of
life in older adults as well as I would
say these pulmonary and cognitive
benefits that our nursing student found
so I think that I hope we see a lot more
research in this area because I think
this is there's a lot of potential there
and the the older population and I know
this because I'm one of them is a
fastest growing population in the United
States so if we can improve the quality
of life for for older Americans I think
that would be um really important and
just one quick note we should expand our
definition of group singing us we Coral
directors uh right because singing in a
high stakes choir where the director is
mad at you if you don't do it right is
maybe not the kind of positive benefit
that we're seeing from some of these
others so providing opportunities for
casual group singing and more inclusive
group singing I think is a direction we
want to think about um and I think
you'll hear some of that from our other
panelists V
[Applause]
[Music]
thanks
she I think I'm
set I'm setting up Julianne and Andre I
hope and there's so much to learn from
science were you reading yesterday about
the we're not hearing very well check
check how about this is this
better
okay let's see how my glasses work
speaking into the microphone were you
reading yesterday about the space probe
that landed on a
comet and then went to sleep and
scientists didn't know what was
happening but then it woke up and it's
now transmitting data from that Comet
science is incredible and we look
forward I think to to finding out what
science says about what we all can talk
about
anecdotally the singing we did in the
beginning was incredible too and let's
think about how it differs from what we
do in other sings at other organizations
we all enjoy those sings at acda and
wherever we are but this was different
there was no music well there was music
but we weren't holding it were we there
were no printed words and we basically
improvised along with
Julianne there was no accompanying
instrument just the sound of our
voices and when we put our individual
voices together we made a beautiful
expressive and Powerful noise we were
reminded that everybody can sing
Julianne gave us voice we each found our
own voice even at 9:00 in the morning
and together we claimed our Collective
voice Julianne's song became Our Song
today and it can never be replicated
again exactly as it sounded a little
while ago it was ours in that particular
moment in time what a gift live music
is perhaps Julianne feels like the
Weavers I don't know if you do or even
if you know who the Weavers
are hey I'm an old broad who wrote in an
introduction to one of their song song
books we do not feel that our songs are
truly ours until they become yours a
song means very little until you have
given it life through your own voice and
shaped it to your own feeling and
singing
style you're probably further along in
your summer reading than I though I
remind us all that summer does not
officially begin until next week the
books on top of my desk are dilia Efron
sister mother husband dog a collection
of essays
Eliza Griswald I am the beggar of the
world it's poetry of Afghan women
Richard Powers the time of our singing a
novel Susan Kain quiet talking about
introversion extraversion and
personality traits Jonathan hate The
Righteous Mind talking about decision
making Karen Armstrong fields of blood
the relationship of religion and War and
finally Alex Ross's listen to this a
collection of essays and this is um I'm
embarrassed to say left over from a
couple of years ago I mention these and
especially Alex Ross's book to let you
in on what I've been thinking about Visa
V this conference and what many of us do
in our day jobs during the Academic Year
how we came to be conductors in the
first place singing
relationships politics War and Peace
those with limited or no voice musical
variety and the ghettoization and
sacralization of different kinds of
music take a minute sometime during
today and think about your musical
Journey Alex Ross describes his in the
simplified version It's Beethoven aroa
malate jazz punk post punk bands and
then back to
Beethoven my journey includes my mother
taking me to hear Benny Goodman and
Teddy Wilson and singing show tunes
around the piano my grandmother an
amateur pianist played brahs and Scott
Joplin and it's possible that I'm one of
the only people in the room today who
has heard the Beatles
live I sang the foray in brahs in high
school and therefore rebelled in college
by singing in and being pitched for an
AC capella group my AC capella identity
was such that one of my classmates in a
conducting class was condescendingly
surprised that I could sing the bronze
from memory including the instrumental
parts so was I a classical or a pop folk
musician I wanted it all
but the Two Worlds were seemingly light
years apart and to inhabit both was
apparently neither acceptable nor
possible because each group was so
dismissive of the other why wasn't it
possible to have a musical life in both
was the brahm's reum really better than
all of the Beatles or just different
both voices spoke to me to my brain and
to my heart
but where was my voice where was the
synthesis of these two seemingly
antithetical
worlds my dilemma seems minor when
compared with the Collision of other
worlds in other lives I think
particularly of religious and cultural
borders which cross differing ethnic
traditions and ensembles which address
these tensions
we have one at this Festival which you
will hear later this week I speak now
though of the Interfaith pontani maqu
spiritual Bridge from Saro Bosnia
heroa formed to include Jews Christians
and Muslims they have tried to in their
words transcend aggression imperialism
and nationalism of the traditional
religions of ethnic Nations and to enter
into the heart of the prayers of these
faiths to sing and bear witness to
messages of trust cooperation and peace
when heard live the voice of this chorus
elicits a powerful reaction from the
audience which originates as much in the
commitment of the
singers as in the quality of their
performance Don sers has said this
whatever people can say with passion and
Julian used the word passion or
Stephanie did it in her description of
Julianne whatever people can say with
passion and en heightened speech they
will end up singing in some form when
life is deeply felt music gives shape
and voice to the very pattern of our
experienced world so the act of singing
together of Life lived and felt binds
heart and mind with ordered
sound I wish I had written
that we can all I hope remember
rehearsals and concerts in which
performers and audience members reacted
strongly I hope I never forget the
audience that laughed because it should
laugh at the extended roll R rolled R in
the paired setting of The geneal ology
of Jesus was the son of the high school
student who after rehearsing sing me to
Heaven told me that her grandmother had
just died and that she and her family
sang to her during her last
days the couple in the front row who
were quietly weeping during a
performance of The Barber Anthony
odily the
flutist with a peaceful beautiful smile
on her face as she listened to the
chorus rehearsed part of the donobi Pam
from the B minor
Mass the men from the shelter who sang
along during Moses Hogan we shall walk
through the valley in peace the singers
reading through for the first time
through their tears both the last letter
home whose text is a letter written to
his family by a soldier who died in
combat and on a lease with texts of van
Frank the clarinetist who said that
anaise was one of the most
transformative musical experiences he
had ever
had the violinist who told us that the
Jackson passion was the most meaningful
music she played during all of Holy Week
watching tearful chorus members during a
performance of the durge for two
Veterans of Von Williams Donan obis
Pacha I think about the multiplicity of
voices at work in these instances the
original Tex texts the librettists the
composers the singers the players these
were without a doubt strong voices and
then I think about the reception of
those voices by ears that listened and
heard who gave what to
whom but what about those voices that
are not so strong those with limited or
no voice we can list many groups
historically think about slaves
struggling ethnic groups think about the
Estonian song festiv festivals with
300,000 singers the labor movement women
anti-war pro peace
African-Americans all of these groups
have
songs and in the present black lives
those with physical and emotional
challenges the prison population the
homeless children the Aged what
responsibility do we have to empower
these people to find and claim a voice
to have songs if categorizing people is
an instrument of power then it is
incumbent on us those who have done the
categorization and still do to ensure a
voice for
all I am involved with Joyful Noise A
Chorus found in 2000 by Allison and Beth
frm its singers have physical and
neurological challenges and acquired
brain injuries the singer and their
friends explain their vision and you can
read about that on their website but it
talks about the skills they develop that
they share their Joy through public
performance alysis Allison is
particularly adamant about the
performance aspect stressing both the
preparation for the performance as well
as the concert
itself all of the singers she says are
used to being stared
at but the stair is transformed into a
look of admiration and respect during
and after a
performance two of the singers say this
it makes me feel famous and
proud I feel confident I was comfortable
my favorite part was the singing I went
up there and conquered my
fear I am a conductor the individuals in
courses I direct could each sing by him
or herself having found and claimed a
voice each could go alone but has chosen
to excuse me to sing with others that we
as an ensemble perform music that is has
variety is beautifully and powerfully
sung and goes well I
hope this goes without saying but today
when it is so easy to isolate ourselves
from one another singers and choruses
want more and so do I we want to have a
sense of emot connection with each other
and with an audience and we want to make
a positive difference in our world this
means we need to reeval re-evaluate
everything from repertoire to how that
repertoire is presented what do we wear
where do we perform when do we perform
to capitalize on the fact that composers
today are not constricted by false genre
boundaries and to combat the sort of
musical snobbery that privileges one
time type of music or one type of
performer over another a few Sundays ago
we celebrated that high holy day in the
UCC children's Sunday one of our
congregation young enough to know better
said she wasn't going to attend because
she feared the music in the service
would resemble an elementary school
recital she did show up of course and
raved about how wonderful it was that it
was so
spiritual of course the kids played well
but I placed the kids offering
strategically so that each piece
including pogo stick worked within the
Liturgy allowing each child's voice to
be
heard Samantha power the United States
ambassador to the UN said the following
at Barnard this spring it is not enough
to find our own voices true equality
also requires that we learn to hear and
to lift up the voices of Those whom
others choose not to hear to paraphrase
Pete Seager songs are seeds let them be
scattered
[Applause]
widely
I I can think of uh no better way to set
me up than uh than Steven's work
Julianne's and uh and Maggie's um so you
can I guess you can see that picture
right
so I started to ask myself the question
uh because you know we always talk about
what we do where we go what we sing but
I wanted to ask myself the question
about about who and how we exclude what
don't we do in other words so I started
to ask myself about questions to do with
exclusion in other words who do we
exclude so where do we not
perform what kinds of formats of
performance do we not Embrace stage
concert formalities just like Maggie was
talking about whose music is not
represented in other words whose music
is
privileged who is not
singing who has no access to singing and
then I started to make a list and the
list is obvious there you can look at
that list and you can see uh and the
only the only group that that's not on
there the temporarily able which is US
essentially uh but but yes you're all
and we all only temporarily able because
you know what's going to happen to us
next right uh and if you look at that
long list we really really are
forgetting about a lot of people and if
you think about 13.4 to 6 16.5 million
American children live in poverty are
they being
included and so I really wanted to talk
about today the Forgotten world because
I think Coral music has forgotten by and
large relatively speaking this a large
chunk of of the American population and
and I wanted to focus specifically on
one aspect on one component of a large
population of people who are
incarcerated and and just in case you
don't know and you might need reminding
how dismal the situation is we with 5%
of the world's population we have 25% of
the world's prisoners one in three
African-American uh males in the in that
age group are in some form of Criminal
Justice supervision and the number of
American women in prison has increased
by 6 146% doesn't it's not because
American women are worse than women
anywhere else but it's because we have
uh I I went through that last night very
quickly because I my colleague is going
to show that you later on
African-Americans now serve virtually as
much time in prison for a nonviolent
offense as whites do for a violent
offense think about that so it's a what
we have is if you if you listen to read
Michelle Alexander's book the new Jim
Crow um mass incarceration in the age of
color blindness and the rich get richer
and the poor get prison America is is
waging a a concerted war against the
poor and the
black and as Joshua dubler says and it's
it's arguable of course but but he makes
a statement statement that we have a a a
prodigious system of torture in our
prisons and and alarmingly
250,000 youth are being tried and
sentenced or incarcerated every year on
any given night 10,000 children are
being held in adult prisons and jails in
this country and you know what that
means for children to be in adult
facilities
and so I ask myself the question what
does coral music have to offer the
Forgotten
World um sorry I'm going to my next my
next uh uh because it was a bit U of A
so so I've been U working in in these uh
two uh sorry here just go go back what
am I doing here
so so I should have been at the front of
this but I'm not okay so I me working in
these two trying to make uh trying to
make a a small a small piece of work in
two Boston prisons this is the Northfolk
Men's
prison this is the Framingham women's
prison this is also the Framingham
women's prison the first the men's
Northfolk prison is where there are 1500
men uh um 700 of whom are there for life
and the Framingham prison is the only
women's prison in Boston which by the
way was originally started for for the
simpleminded the feeble-minded the
Indigent the homeless women or for uh
very often for for mistresses of rich
men uh who went who went to prison for
being pregnant um and I mean we we have
uh started an approach in the prisons
called empowering song and and the
empowering song approach is an is an
approach that my colleagues Emily how uh
who presenting later on today and Jamie
Hillman and I have have uh developed as
an approach really reflecting on on some
of the work that that Maggie was talking
about about empowering people we talk
about we talk about song as a
channel to
poetry and to song creation I'm going to
give you one simple example one story
that we had um we had a a young woman we
have in this women's prison Emily how
and I were work together one session and
we we sang this song uh without without
music we sang Do Lord Do Lord you know
the song Sing With Me Do Lord Do Lord do
remember Me Do Lord Do Lord
[Music]
do beond
the you sing beautifully so at the end
of that at the end of that song we asked
the women so what might the blue mean
and they and they said well the blue
might mean uh the ocean death suffering
Redemption salvation and the ocean and
so on and so one we asked him to write
and and one of the women wrote this I'll
read it out to you minutes now feel like
eternity always you are out of grasp
always You Out Of Reach beyond my grasp
swallow whole so far beyond the blue how
quickly sorrow comes to song and it
drags the meaning forth from everything
and I die to say I missed you i' laid it
be to say I cared but my heart still
wears its wanting Way Beyond the
blue this is another example of a of a
of a young man uh young man's work uh
I'm going to sorry I'm going to
introduce it before I speak about it uh
we had we had a we had a group of of men
together and and once again talking
about how song is a channel to um to
poetry and then poetry back into song
because we sang those those poems back
and uh in this group of men they were um
they were they were doing an improvised
piece at the end of the semester and and
and this man had been young man had been
relatively quiet for the for the for the
whole uh semester shy I would say and
then he when he stood up in this
improvisation and he wrapped this this
poem and I'm going to read it out to
you he says how can one stare deeply
into my eyes and don't see innocence my
adolesence taken away from me in
handcuffs because of one misstep in my
misguided life misread misjudged and
misunderstood by the blinded but never
nearly once in my adolescence had anyone
listened or let me explained my
misbehavior to an adult in order to to
comprehend an adolescent's mind as to
why a child could commit a crime because
of one mistake I'm misled and
misrepresented by dominions playing the
double standard of the law which my
family my future and my faith are fading
away slowly like dark clouds covering
the sunny sky and my Smiles turn into
frowns frightening and fighting off a
dark shadow that isn't mine listen to my
own tears pouring and pounding off the
concrete floor ripping my heart out for
attention in order for anyone to Hear My
Cries Beyond these Barb wires White
Walls screaming for someone to help save
my adolescence Behind These cell doors
I'm just a child misplaced in a machine
without mercy and I'm missing my mother
warmth who nurtured me to become
somebody the future of today's society
yet my adolescence
gone and when he finished wrapping this
poem uh in this in this group
improvisation piece uh we were all
stunned really no no one could speak and
then and then he said that's the first
time in my life that anybody had stopped
and listened to me and I thought about
how powerful that was that a moment had
happened that through music um a young
man who obviously had hadn't had the ear
of of his family Society had found a
moment to be heard in the context of our
work uh and so the so they we think
about the our work as a as a as a
channel to the self to the group to the
art form to the other Arts poetry Visual
Arts narrative journaling theater and so
on here's another story uh this is this
is a a a a Young Man U uh well he's not
a young man anymore he's 53 he was uh
sentenced as a child to die in
prison uh and as as America was one of
the two countries in the world which
which hasn't ratified the International
Convention on the rights of the child
and America was allowed to sentence
children to die in prison until 2012
when the Supreme Court uh in Alabama
versus Miller um overturned that as a
it's unconstitutional now to to S his
children to die in prison and he was up
for for uh for parole and he's now we're
happy to say in pre-release after 35 or
so years in prison and he did this uh
wonderful piece of art and in in the in
the Northfolk prison they don't really
have access to paint they very often
dissolve M&M's to to to to make paint
and they cut their hair they've got hair
to u to make paint brushes and so on I'm
not sure how he did this but but on that
wall you see the the names of all the
people who are condemned uh to life and
to be to die in prison and the people
who actually died in prison and so he
did this painting and he said at the end
I have never drawn I have never I have
never created anything artistic and when
he went to the parole board he said that
one of the most powerful things that
changed his life when he was in prison
was uh the experience of
Music um this is uh and you can't see it
very well unfortunately
but you can see the mus the musical
keyboard I'm going to read out to you
one last because I'm out of time but at
the end we we we we will take some
questions and and um uh I would just
want to this is these two small extracts
by one particular
uh man and he says he says
that um men who so often have not been
properly socialized or initiated into
manhood in constructive ways through
your examples and the authenticity of
Love which you bring with you many of us
gained confidence which allowed us to
shatter many Illusions and increased our
ability to seek and attain truth
together truth that all remain equal and
loved no one is discarded tossed away
forgotten and the same man uh who um
spoke about about a moment of
vulnerability a moment of vulnerability
in the music session he
wrote um I love music it has become my
bridge to the world a child given up at
Birth sexually abused uh from the age of
6 to 8 dealing with many abandonment and
Trust Issues fighting to survive and
keep the music within alive a Professor
consoling hug to a wounded child of
52 inclusion I'm not allowed to hug in
the prison but I
do um so um we'll we'll be happy to take
questions at the end after all our
sessions are uh uh presentations are
over thank you all very much so I just
want to want to say my closing comment
is that that I want to resonate the
what's been said earlier that that we
have an obligation we have this
wonderful thing called Cor music and
there are extraordinary things happening
there are models for excellence there
are models for transforming the world
within Coral
music we have to use Coral music not to
protect and prop up the status quo we
have to use Coral music this wonderful
thing called Coral music as an
instrument of change to harness
ourselves in the service of a better
world thank you very
[Applause]
much
that's my last slide so you get a little
sneak preview
now there we
go as I mentioned earlier I'm a
board-certified music therapist um which
means that I get to do all of these
things that everyone on the panel has
been talking about every day I use music
in these intentional clinical ways to
help transform lives and change
lives I'm going to give you uh the the
official definition of music therapy
because I've learned in my travels that
not everybody nobody really has any idea
what that is so um so here we go what is
a music therapist a music therapist is a
credentialed professional who is trained
in the clinical use of Music
interventions to accomplish
individualized goals within a
therapeutic
relationship so the key piece of that is
individualized
goals music therapy is not a
prescriptive program there's no one siiz
fits all sometimes people ask me so so
what music do you do you use to treat
ADHD or
Autism the answer is there is no music
that I can use to treat ADH or Autism it
all depends um there are as many
different musical interventions as there
are humans on the planet um each session
that we do is tailored specifically to
each individual based on his or her
needs their musical preferences their
goals and we establish these goals by
doing an assessment and by working with
um other members of their treatment team
so very
individualized and music therapy by the
book is an evidence-based Health Care
profession that uses music to address a
variety of goals including cognitive
physical social emotional and spiritual
needs of indivi individuals across the
lifespan so some of the things that
you've been hearing the other people
talk about today that we want to try to
encourage um all of these
goals um interesting I'm finding in my
work um in other places in the world I'm
having to sort of think about these
definitions and how they really relate
out in in other cultures in other
countries how I can be flexible and
adapt these definitions to the people
that I'm working with so that's a work
in progress at the moment um so
additionally about music therapy uh
because of the power of music that as
you all know and have experienced we can
often reach those individuals
that maybe other more traditional
therapies are not able to help so um I'm
going to give you a couple of examples
throughout my presentation but one uh
one that has been very well documented
is uh is the example of Alzheimer's
disease you you may have heard this in
in some popular research uh but it it
has been well documented that
individuals with Alzheimer's disease who
have uh forgotten their friends and
their family members who who don't know
their own name they can actually still
sing familiar songs from their childhood
so it's one of the last things to go um
and why is that well there's there's a
couple reasons one of them is that um
music is
actually there we go music is what we
call a whole brain experience um so it
activates a lot of different areas of
the brain when we're singing or engaging
in music making
and as um Dr Oliver Sach said nothing
activates the brain so extensively as
music and he's a professor of Neurology
at Columbia and he's written a number of
books including
musicophilia uh there's a lot of really
really interesting brain research going
on right now and we heard a little bit
about it earlier uh but through fmri
Imaging scientists have been able to map
some of the brain some of the brain's uh
many functions to to specific regions
and what they're finding is that music
actually lights up many areas across
both hemispheres of the brain including
you know oral areas visual motor
coordination areas language areas it's
kind of lighting up a whole lot in there
as well as areas um that are involved
with memory and
emotion so what this means is that if
one area of the brain is compromised or
damaged in some way there are still many
other points of access when using music
because it it is such a whole brain
experience and music can actually end up
helping to stimulate the brain to even
create new neural Pathways and
connections so there's really really
exciting stuff going on right now in in
the field of um neurology and and
studying this um for example I want to
share a couple of case studies uh from
my own work which is in the Cayman
Islands I I started the first music
therapy practice in the Cayman Islands
um so the next couple of um examples I'm
going to give you are from my work there
so we currently have a patient who I'll
call Mr a and he suffered multiple
severe strokes and he was diagnosed with
Aphasia which um is essentially the
inability to speak because of damage to
the language areas of the
brain when we first met Mr a the only
thing that he was was able to say at all
was y y y y y y y that was all that he
could say he had been working with a
speech therapist for a while um and she
was unable to elicit any further
language from him so he was referred to
us as often happens when people don't
know what to do with anyone they send
them to the music therapist uh to see
what we could do so we came in and we
started using some um music therapy
singing techniques and by the end of the
very first session this man even though
he was unable to speak he could still
manage to complete the ends the final
word of familiar songs with the proper
word and the proper timing so he could
not say anything but yah but he would
fill
in Jesus loves me this I
know and then by the next session Mr a
was singing short musical phrases along
with us and we were playing the guitar
and singing with him we continued
working with him and in time he was not
only able to sing longer and longer
phrases but his brain began to pave new
Pathways around the damaged areas and he
was able to transfer this singing
ability into actual speech and he can
now communicate in full sentences in
fact not perfectly but the other day he
grabbed my hands and looked into my eyes
and he said to me thank you for teaching
me you do good work
which was an amazingly powerful moment
for me and singing transforming
lives there are other well-known
examples of this too you may be familiar
with Gabrielle gord's a congresswoman
who was um shot in the head there's uh
there's a link in in the handout that we
gave you to some videos about her using
music therapy to help regain Her speech
ability so if you're interested in
learning more about that you can check
out that
video um another example kind of going
along a similar path as Andre was is
talking about um singing as a Lifeline
as a connection um and in this case the
singing was
rapping uh so another example of Music
reaching even those individuals that
traditional therapies might not be able
to help one of my favorite groups to
work with are is teenagers and as you
may have experienced in your own lives
if your parents or if you know any
teenagers teenagers are sometimes not
the easiest to talk
to um and though are going through very
difficult and confusing times and they
really need to connect and express
themselves so what I found in my work is
that music and in particular singing or
rapping um Can often be one of the only
ways to reach these kids and help them
Express themselves and get the support
that they so desperately
need so one of the schools that I work
in is a really tough school there are
gangs drugs weapons a lot of treny you
name it this this school has some some
some tough kids in it um and as happens
we were given a group of boys to work
with who are the toughest guys in the
school who nobody else knew what to do
with so what did we do we started
singing We started rapping we connected
with them where they were and engaged
with them through rap and these boys
some of whom are actual gang members
some of whom who have been rejected by
their own parents all of whom Rebel in
school um are now coming to our Music
Therapy Group religiously which by the
way is on a Friday afternoon the last
period of the day which is not the most
focused time they come every week on
Friday afternoon and and sometimes
staying till after the Bell Rings uh
because they're so engaged in writing
songs in rapping together and sharing
their hopes their dreams their their the
reality of their daily lives with each
other and with us so another example
singing transforming lives every day
my final example that I'd like to share
with you is a group that is very close
to my heart and this um Taps into a
little bit what Maggie was
saying I first met these amazing
individuals five years ago about five
years ago this week actually and they
touched me profoundly with their
enthusiasm their joy and their
excitement about singing with me and
singing together these lovely singers um
that I'm going to talk about attend a
day program for individuals with
disabilities and they all have special
needs or disabilities of of some kind
from those who are severely multiply
disabled and impaired and non-verbal to
those who just have mild challenges
cognitively or
otherwise uh to set the stage a little
bit in the Caribbean um we are a little
bit behind in terms of services for and
even recognition of people with
disabilities we are getting there we
have a disabilities policy that's going
through government at the moment
um and it's actually was not that long
ago that individual individuals with
disabilities were actually hidden away
in homes due to the shame on the family
and not to mention the lack of services
so this day program is actually tucked
up way in a remote corner of the island
where people don't ever visit them or
see them and these individuals have
historically had little or no voice in
the community so it has been one of my
missions to imp Empower them to find
their own voices and to find their place
in the community Through
singing so I would like to play a short
clip for you I started this chorus in
2010 so five years
ago um and though at the at the
beginning it was very hard for them to
maintain focus and attention to even sit
in the room for the whole rehearsal they
were very excited and very determined to
succeed they have since performed a
Christmas and a spring concert every
year they love every minute of their
chance to shine on the stage and they
talk about their concerts for months
before and after and the changes that I
have seen in them individually and as a
group are
tremendous I'm also proud to report that
because of this chus these individuals
have been featured in the paper on local
television they've been interviewed by
reporters and they've even had the top
leaders of the country including
multiple ministers attend their concerts
talk about giving of
voice so this is one of the best
examples that I personally know of the
power of singing to transform lives
before I play it I will let you know
that the goals of this group are uh at
this point to to maybe sing
approximately the same words at
approximately the same time so we are
not going for Coral Perfection here
we're going for inclusion and giving
people a chance to experience singing
together so with that in mind I present
you the sunrise
chorus uh with that in mind I present
[Music]
[Applause]
chorus the choice we're making
we
[Music]
our
you
[Applause]
all right they
wonderful they'll be very excited to
know that they got to sing at Yale
University so I will pass that on thank
[Applause]
you we have uh six or seven minutes for
uh questions comments interrogations
disagreements other there microphones in
both aisles so please feel free to walk
to a microphone
and yes
Francisco
well we we get we can't even take a
click pen inside so so uh no we we can
we we have in each in both the men's and
the women's prisons we have a we have an
electric keyboard that that was is
relatively kind Museum pieces but
they're but they're there uh there are
there are um there are there are no
other instruments that that we use um
essentially we work with the voice and
the body since there are no auditions to
be apart from being part of our
universities program there there since
there are no auditions to join the class
uh we also have issues to do with uh
pitch matching accuracy of singing uh we
have we have people who can sing very
well and we have people who for whom
singing is a first experience and that's
also profoundly beautiful to have to
have people who've never had U never had
chance to sing to find as Maggie says to
find voice to find their voices and to
find
voice
okay U I'm only standing here as as the
chair of the panel so so please don't
feel you have to direct questions to me
but can you repeat question the question
was the Jean batist beron asked if I
could say something about the the the
prison Choir in Indonesia with which I
worked uh last last summer uh
there it was unprecedented that a choir
flew from one part of the country to the
other I have a festival in Bali that I
direct and so a prison choir came from
from the island island of Papa to Bali
and and they arrived it was actually
quite strange Emily and I were there
Emily how and I were there in Bali
were're waiting for them we got a phone
call to say that they the prison choir
was waiting for us U and they' arrived
and we and they were we went to the
prison and he said we said um are they
are they men or women and the person
didn't know and and we thought we we
dressed we you know em wasn't sure what
to dress because you know here when you
go to prison you really have to be
careful no cleavage no no no skin you
know the kind of thing you know uh that
that you have to dress very
appropriately when you go to so so Emily
wore some of my clothes you know where's
Emily there's Emily Emily Emily
disgraced herself by wearing by wearing
my clothes and wearing my my sneakers
and so on we went so we we drove to the
prison and and when we got out at the
the in the in the parking lot there was
a group of people out there and we said
well who are they and and these were
outside the prison in the parking lot
was were the prison choir so I mean we
we were staggered we said you know and
and then there were was turn that there
were men and there were women and and
they seemed to be just just a
homogeneous group and they seem be a
couple of kids there to we said well who
are the prisoners I mean yes the me the
men are the prisoners and the women are
the prisoners and and they said well
there seemly no staff well yes the staff
are there well and who's the staff well
the staff and the prisoners were
indistinguishable because they all
wearing similar kinds of clothing and
there were a couple of kids there who
were a a couple of kids of Staff members
and and so it was it began a few days of
this really quite extraordinary
experience of working with these um
prisoners who are both uh Muslims and
Christians uh from this island of Papa
and and they were they were working with
us in the campus of the art center and I
remember having to say to them I said to
them once why don't you escape you
know I said I just have I have to ask
you that question because because when I
go back to Boston and tell my my prison
men and women I'm going to ask them I'm
going to tell them that I asked you why
don't you escape I'm just Escape godamn
it and and they said and I know Emily
was there time and and they said you
know Escape where to what what would we
do you know and and said but I said you
could Escape you could but you know we
got our families there and they come and
visit us and and and so it was really it
was a profound experience of
understanding incarceration Humanity
community in a completely different
setting and here we were we did a we did
a we did some musical work and and they
did a performance with us together and
and they had Spears and they were
dancing with Spears and I just thought
it it's fantastic he these he these
prisoners dancing with Spears and
you I'm in the middle of
them uh I I I feel I feel we're almost
almost out in fact we are out it's 10:16
so I you know we're supposed to finish
at 10:15 if there's one more question I
suppose we could take it but otherwise
we're we're here we're not disappearing
we're happy to talk to you in the break
yes
forance
to good Coral groups but then what we're
also here about
cisions you
knows of excellence in your church or
your groups and
then
know
IDE
that's
tough that's that's so tough I have no
idea if this is making me audible um my
sort of off-the-cuff reaction to that is
that in the academy it's very difficult
to do that um in the academy however it
is possible to partner with other
ensembles um whether it's Joyful Noise
seeing with the Harvard collegium uh in
New Jersey and at Harvard um that there
are are ways of doing that um which
expose our students to other ways of
making music and I hope encourages them
to to go out and do uh something similar
um through no um efforts of my own um
completely on her own before she came to
Yale one of our students was
instrumental in starting a homeless
choir had nothing to do with anything
that we did and she in fact informed us
when she came here um in terms of our
work with people so so that it works
really both ways um we hope they catch
the students catch some of this and can
can do better perhaps than we have in
Colleges and Schools of making those two
worlds come together so as that for a a
a really fuzzy answer to your
question ladies and Gentlemen please
thank our panels Steven demarez Maggie
Brooks
[Applause]
par
than
sure
we haven't started yet so you don't have
to be so
[Music]
quiet
Church
C
uh
welcome back for our second panel what
happens in rehearsal and
performance since the fall of 2003
Jeffrey dhama has served as director of
the Yale Glee Club he also serves as
professor of conducting at the Yale
School of Music where he teaches in The
Graduate Coral program and as founding
director of the Yale Coral artists
author and reporter Stacy horn has
written five non-fiction books the most
recent one titled imperfect Harmony
finding happiness singing with
others active nationally and
internationally as a guest conductor and
lecturer Anton Armstrong became the
fourth conductor of the St Olaf Choir in
1990 after 10 years in Grand Rapids
Michigan where he had served on the
faculty of Calvin College Molly Stone
served serves as the Director of world
music at Chicago Children's Choir and
the assistant director of coral
activities at University of Chicago she
is also the co-founder and director of
both the Brooklyn World music chorus and
the Chicago World music chorus and
teaches across the US Europe and Africa
as a teacher for Village
Harmony thanks Stephanie uh and I want
to thank uh Andre and Stephen and uh
and Julianne for such a
thought-provoking and uh engaging and
wide reaching uh discussion I really
can't imagine a better beginning to uh
not only today's Symposium but to our to
our Festival this week uh this panel uh
has a very different charge uh our
charge is to talk about whether there
are specific practices that a conductor
can engage in or that singers can engage
in in rehearsal or performance that
increase the possibility for
transformative experiences on the part
of the singer or the audience member so
I also want to thank Tom cabanis
actually because uh the question that
you asked Maggie at the end of the last
panel is a perfect segue to this
discussion uh those of us who have day
jobs and for whom uh singing In Tune is
important and getting the vowel right is
important and yet uh we recognize that
Coral music has the power to do so much
more and reach other people and how so
how do we actually make make that happen
uh the four of us had a conversation on
the phone a few weeks ago and a few
questions emerged from that conversation
and uh so that will form the basis of
our conversation this morning uh and
hopefully there'll be a little bit of
time for questions at the end and by the
way I I'll just mention now while it's
on my mind if if you do have a question
uh we hope that you'll step up to one of
these two microphones because uh our
Symposium today is being live streamed
and so if any everybody uh happens to be
watching it uh via the Internet uh we
want them to hear your question too
which they can if you use these
microphones so uh as a starting point uh
first I'd like to ask uh Anton about
something that I heard you say probably
at least 15 years ago uh during a
keynote uh address that you gave at the
Oregon Bach festival and uh what you
said was that you did not believe as
part of this discussion you did not
believe in the moral art and that made
quite an impression on me as a young
conductor wasn't something that I was
expecting to hear come out of the mouth
of the conductor of the St Olaf choir
which is of course something that I
think most of us in our profession
consider to be an Exemplar of the coral
art so could you tell us a little bit
about what what you meant by that well
you have a good memory
um I I think actually how I reference is
that I don't worship the Cor Coral art
and I think when I started off in this
business 35 years ago and in especially
in the academy especially graduate
school it was about holding up the coral
art as the highest uh it felt almost
like a religion you know you go to an
acda convention you hear these wonderful
choirs you worship before the throne and
then you go away and and I guess over
the years what I still work for
excellence but I work for excellence so
that all all the things that can
distract the human mind and ear are not
there but ultimately if it doesn't touch
the heart of the performer it doesn't
touch the heart of the listener then the
music's not working and I guess in large
part for me it comes from my work with
children over the years um who come and
they just want to play together they
want to sing together and then you have
mentors and the one I really give credit
to this some of you who've worked with
children's choirs and church choirs
especially you'll know the name of Helen
Kemp and you know know a mantra of hers
for her teaching has been Body Mind
spirit voice it takes the whole person
to sing and enjoys and I think we can
get so caught up in the mechanics and
the techniques that we forget we have
people who come to our choirs because
they need to belong they need to be
fed and and and so it's not so much
about the coral art the Excellence of
the coral art it's how are we why should
those people come even if they are in
the academy and have to be there for
some reason
then is it a meaningful experience are
they being changed or they being
transformed so for me it it really isn't
about um it really isn't about the the I
yeah I I do see Coral xon I I
appreciated mag's response it was a very
honest one but people want to do things
well in life I don't care whatever you
do if you build you build something you
want to do it well in life when you sing
you want to do it well in life but what
what's beyond it has to go beyond
entertainment but coming at it from the
other side if if the other things are in
place if the sense of community is in
place and the sense of purpose is there
then do you think that uh you coming
back to the idea of the coral art do you
think that when those things are also at
the highest possible level that it has a
positive impact on the other
non-musical uh aspects I mean does it
does it feed both ways yeah I think for
me and then I want my colleagues to
answer this
um I I really do think that people want
to do whatever they do in life well they
don't want to do things in a halfhazard
way so you know when I played Sports
yeah it was great when we won but it was
even better you know if we were playing
together not not fighting each other you
know out in the soccer field um It's a
combination that you go and for me it's
it's it's giving you never know when
what you're doing will give meaning to
somebody else you know you know just
being nice to somebody you know there's
there was a time at the at the airport
when I didn't I was the one person the
woman said didn't cuss it all day
because the flight had been delayed she
said you're actually nice to me the
niess came she upgraded me
okay but my mother let she said ugly you
know nice gets nice ugly gets squat okay
and in making music why do we why don't
we go for the nice why don't we go for
the beautiful our people live in a world
of ugliness of pain I want to give him
Joy if we're gonna spend an hour
together let's do it and have some fun
with it you know and let's have
something we can look at at the end of
the time and say we've actually
accomplished something yeah so go ahead
Stacey I I wanted to respond to two
things you said first um I Do Worship
the coral art and I'm one of those
people that you spoke about who needs to
be there and I found this great quote
when I was researching my book it was
from an immigrant to America um from
Wales in the 19th century and he said
the ease from mental pain that other men
have sought in alcohol I always found in
song and I love this quote because I
originally tried to find ease from
mental pain in alcohol and that so did
not work and I joined a choir instead
and choir did work and now it just
continues to always provide that um ease
for mental pain I like how that puts and
all also I wanted to address your point
about people wanting to be good at what
they do and I'm a strictly amateur
singer when I joined that Coral Society
I was in my 20s I'd never been in a
choir before and the first time you know
at a rehearsal and I had to read music I
mean I I knew a little bit but I just
had no idea of how to turn those musical
words into song musical notes into songs
so it's very hard for me but then about
um 10 or 15 years ago I I don't remember
exactly when this um man named John mlay
took over the choir and he just very
slowly slowly slowly started giving us
more and more challenging pieces and it
was it was difficult for me and the only
way I could do it was by rehearsing at
home during the week but I love it I and
and now I'm at that point where if he
gives us a piece that isn't challenging
enough I don't I I'm disappointed I have
to to say the the the more it pushes me
to be a little bit better the better it
feels for me so let me dive into a
couple of the questions that we' uh
talked about a few weeks ago because I
can tell we're already you know we're
already getting into some of that maybe
Molly uh you can try to respond to this
first uh can you recount specific
instances uh when you have personally
felt the transformative impact of group
singing either in a rehearsal setting or
in a performance setting
oh so many um but I guess I guess I can
start from this and tie this together uh
with what we were saying before and I
think Excellence is a word that keeps
coming up and it's a word that a lot of
us are afraid to talk about um but I
want to sort of preent present a
different way of thinking about it um
the times we're striving for excellence
in Coral music um don't work anymore for
me is when people use the idea of
Excellence to alienate people when
people talk about the coral art as
something that is intangible it's
something we can only reach for um it is
something so wonderful that or not even
wonderful but so high and mighty that
none of us can touch it and it can't
actually be a part of us and we can't be
a part of it um but I believe that
striving for excellence is what should
make music accessible and not alienating
and that one of the most powerful
experiences one can have in in striving
for um just to have the coral experience
is to engage in that challenge that that
there's this idea where you're when
you're in a coral setting and you
actually have to make yourself
vulnerable and engage in the challenge
to strive for excellence that that is
actually what draws you in and that is
the greatest act of creating Community
if it's easy if it's too easy like what
you were saying it doesn't mean very
much um and so and so this idea of
striving for excellence it should be the
thing that engages us most and makes the
music accessible and not the thing that
alienates us and you know this happens
on a regular basis especially when you
work with with young people I feel
because there's um it happens in in both
ways I work with adults as well and
sometimes I see some of the most
powerful emotional breakthroughs with
adults when they're faced with a
challenge because their instinct is to
say I can't do this and then when you
when you work really hard with them and
show show them that they can it is truly
an incredible experience and once
they've had that experience they are
they're hooked for life um not just in
the music but in that that act of
engaging in challenge especially in an
area where they're not they don't have
expertise because we all know it's
really easy to do something we're good
at it's really hard the older we get to
do something that we're not good at um
but then the the successes are even more
powerful but also with young people um I
feel that some of the most
transformative experiences is when you
challenge them to go beyond what they
think they're capable of and then they
find that they can in fact do something
they never knew they could do before um
and you know even if you look at
Julianne's choir that that she showed us
I'm sure that when she first met them
she didn't think that they could reach
that level of Excellence so obviously
it's all contextual as well um but yeah
I think that striving for excellence is
not a bad thing it's just that we have
to do it in a way that makes our our
genre accessible and not alienating does
that make sense yeah very much well
interestingly I I just a few days ago I
was interviewed by the public radio
station here in town about this festival
and of course we're talking about the
choirs coming we're talking about the
Symposium and the kind of ideas that
we're going to explore and the the
interviewer basically asked me uh who's
a musician herself actually uh asked me
kind the same question
and strangely even though we all believe
you know I think very um very strongly
in uh Coral music's ability to create
these kinds of transformative
experiences actually wasn't easy for me
to think of one maybe it's because
there's too much pressure to think of
the perfect you know what is the
quintessential example of this and the
first thing that popped into mind which
actually I'll just I'll just share now
uh was a very ordinary uh kind of this
kind of thing that happens every day but
it it did happen to be the first thing
that popped into my mind a couple years
ago with the Glee Club we're getting
ready for our joint concert with Harvard
I'm Sor this is the second time Harvard
has come up at the Symposium already we
have
to we have to rethink that somehow I
think but uh we're rehearsing for the
GLE club's joint concert with Harvard
and uh we're rehearsing a very simple
piece very beautiful piece Joe
flummerfelt arrangement of Danny Boy and
as I often do I walked off the stage
stopped conducting and went out into the
audience you hear how things sounded in
the hall but what I think was different
is that I I happened to do that at the
moment when uh well we do the second
verse really really soft which you know
I think way most people do it and that's
when I
left and because everybody had to sing
so quietly and we were alone in this
Hall and they no longer had a conductor
you could tell that just the level of
concentration went up several notches
and they sang it frankly you know much
more beautifully than they would have
sung it it while I was conducting and uh
and I think they all could they all
sensed that in that moment and and that
impression of mine
was was verified later on several of the
students kind of came up and even Weeks
Later said wasn't that that was really
kind of something special and so the
other day when this popped into my head
I realized that maybe the reason that
was the first thing that occurred to me
is that that's kind of a powerful
metaphor uh for us as
conductors uh who are trained to lead in
so many specific ways and and we do we
have to but uh here was this
very beautiful and profound moment and
of course that was the moment when I was
completely getting out of their way and
not and not getting in their face um so
uh that's that's something that I've
I've I've thought back on several times
since since that last happened I could
give give you a specific example I
cheated and didn't really answer your
question but I can give you one that's
similar but from a children's choir
perspective um in terms of just the
transformative nature and when we
suddenly get out of the way and let our
singers come to the music I I was
teaching a group of inner city um
teenagers um a late Renaissance motet
last year by yakob hondel called duntin
fantes which is not performed very often
because the text is pretty morbid it's
about uh King Herod slaying all of the
children and I picked it mostly because
it had some of the most gorgeous
Counterpoint and I wanted to really work
with the kids on what it meant for a
composer to set text in different ways
how composers use different textures
poony homophony and these are a bunch of
in City you know Chicago kids mostly
African-American um who have come from
very poor poor backgrounds and this is
the music that that is supposed to
alienate them and they they don't even
know that it's supposed to alienate them
they they hear the music they sing
through it and they fall in love with it
and I was talking to them about my own
struggle with I chose this piece of
music for you because of the music and
I'm sorry about the text and they said
why are you sorry and I said I don't
know how you can relate to this can you
and they they looked at the text and the
translation and they sang through it um
again and they said well first of all I
feel it when I sing this music I feel it
and another kid said I feel it too but I
can also relate it to something in our
own lives we know a lot about young
people being slaughtered in this day and
age and feeling like the authorities
don't help and sometimes are even
responsible and they started talking
about uh another girl who went to school
with them who had recently been caught
in gun violence in their neighborhood
and was murdered and going to her
funeral and they were saying that this
song is all about giving voices giving a
voice to to the voices of the children
who were slaughtered and never had a
voice and they were saying that by
singing this song they were giving a
voice to their friends and I just
couldn't believe how they made it so
instantly accessible and related it so
clearly to their own experiences um and
that was magical because here was this
repertoire that was composed in the late
Renaissance and you know I was
introducing it to them as a motet to
talk about homophony and pany and there
they made it directly connected to their
own lives and that was really a moment
of of transformation and reminding me
that this Coral art really lives and
breathes in all of us and that it's it's
actually given new life when we allow
our singers to find their own
relationships to it that's some of the
magic that happens in rehearsal and in a
sense you were also getting out of the
way when you when you did that I mean
that wasn't your idea to bring them to
that to that conclusion well the second
question that we had talked about which
is of course very closely related all of
this is are are there there specific
things a conductor can do in rehearsal
to create that sense of community uh and
to allow for that possibility um well I
don't know uh either Anton or Molly as
conductors or Stacy as a as a coral
singer I certainly have suggestions all
right yeah let's hear
it well I I wanted to tell a quick story
about my transforma moment because it
kind of leads to what I'm going to talk
about but it was when I was demoted from
singing soprano 1 to soprano
[Laughter]
2 and I I only found out like the first
night of rehearsal for the season when
the conductor handed out sheets with our
voice parts and I just had no time to
react otherwise I would have just burst
into tears and sobbed for a while and he
raised his hands and so I pulled out the
music and I couldn't find my entrance
note I just had no experience with
finding an entrance note somewhere in
the middle and every time I tried I got
it wrong it was horrible I was miserable
I was making everyone else around me
miserable and I'll never forget I just
looked around at other voice all the
other voice parts and I said oh my God
is it if this is what they have to do
all the time why did they even bothered
coming and then eventually I found the
right note totally by accident
and I was pinned to that note because I
was by vibrating in harmony with the
voices around me in a way that I had
just never felt before singing soprano 1
singing The Melody and I don't really
know the explanation for this and I have
since done everything I can to research
it when I when I worked on my book about
the science of singing and the history
of singing I read every study I could
find and I found almost nothing that
specifically looked at singing In
Harmony which just surprised me because
for me it really is the best best part
and that leads me to my suggestion
another thing my conductor did um a
couple years after he took over the
choir was he separated us from singing
um voice Parts in sections to singing
with the voice Parts all mixed up in
quartets and that is probably the change
that he made that had the most positive
effect um on me and I know for the
singers in my choir because I
interviewed all of them and everyone
again and again and again talked about
how singing cets made them feel the
harmony physically from head to toe in a
way that they never had before and now
we all crave it and I just got some
great quotes from people when I when I
asked them to describe the experience
some person said it was like one person
said it was going like going from two
Dimensions to three one said it was like
making a hologram out of thin air and
one person said most importantly um
there aren't too many other chances in
ordinary life to be in perfect
cooperation with other people so my
suggestion is break up um from singing
into sections into
quartets antonor
Molly I'm just I'm just smiling because
I'm a second soprano and I feel really
validated now just imagine being an
alto it's probably even
better I actually made my singers this
year um switch voice Parts on every song
and I that was also a revelation they
were so mad at me oh my God unch I I
destroyed their identity apparently um
but no they they also really appreciated
uh it was an amazing experience for them
to have to switch voice Parts all
constantly and yeah I can imagine yeah
yeah I've I've been doing more more and
more of that um I guess you know for me
it it's originally stemmed from the fact
that it seemed like the tuning was
better when we did that that uh at least
for for us but um you know I wasn't
thinking about the experience with the
singer but of course I was getting that
kind of feedback from the students as
well I I'll throw in a general thing and
then kind of two two specific things
that I found stem from that uh I think a
very important practice for me as a
conductor is to try to especially like
at the beginning of every rehearsal to
remind myself of
the the sacrifice that the individual
ual singers are making you all these
people who show up week after week month
after month they come there uh you know
they're they're singers in the GLE Club
are not getting paid money most they're
not getting academic credit most of them
are not even music Majors uh and that
even if sometimes they seem tired or
distracted by other things the truth is
I I I believe the by and large the large
majority of them are doing the absolute
best they can in that moment they're
there because they want to make
beautiful music they're not there to
frustrate me you know
they're right they're
there they're there because they want to
sing they want to they want to make
something it's very I think a very
genuine uh contribution that they're
that they're making and so two ways that
that's that that's affected me in my
practice I guess is that uh it's changed
the way I think about gesture because uh
if I think of a conductor show is always
showing things that have nothing to do
with the sound that they want uh that
that's it's not only that
it's um not efficient in terms of
getting what you want but it's actually
kind of disrespectful to the singers and
the time that they're putting in that
then they they show up and finally
you're you're the one who's supposed to
be ready and you're giving them all of
this information that uh is counter to
the sound that they want and and another
thing that I've tried to do for a long
time and still fail miserably in fact
just a couple days ago in rehearsal I
was just asking myself why do you keep
doing this this but I I tell this my
conducting students all the time to try
to avoid using the first person when
they're talking you know I I want can I
think this should be in a certain way um
and you know maybe in part that sort of
group psychology but I think it's also
just a healthy reminder for the
conductor that you're not supposed to be
the focus of what's going on and that's
just a way that's just a way of
reminding myself I
guess
ditto to all you what you've said I'm
going to say I think a lot of a lot of
what has come about over the years for
me is can that experience be one people
come whether it's your church choir
whether it's
your whether it's the academy whether
it's the choir as Andre was sharing with
us earlier that comes together in prison
people want to come together because
they want to
belong people want to belong to
something and they want to belong to
where they're
important
um and I think this whole relational
aspect of coming together of being part
of something doing something more than
you could do by yourself alone making
something more beautiful than you can do
as one and when there are those times of
silence and music that are the most
beautiful but there are also those times
when I think when you are in communal
song whether you're in a choir
or whether you're do just singing as
Community sometimes and you start to
listen to someone
else and there's an exercise in life I
keep saying if we could put Congress and
the White House maybe in a choir to sing
they would learn to govern better
because they would listen to each
[Applause]
other but I don't think we listen a
lot and as much as a public performance
is important for me it's it's the time
we spend together in rehearsal you know
you know that that magical moment may
not happen in the public performance but
maybe all that goose bump moment that
you mentioned would you know and I've
had the same thing with Danny Boy get
out of their way Sopranos won't get
freaked up when they have to go to that
high G and you just stop and there are
times I just stop conducting because to
conduct it just gets in their
way um but I think the whole
idea of what does that time together
mean when they come together at in
whatever circumstance you have you know
most of you know me as conducting the
single choir the other part of my life
every week is
110 women ages 18 to 70 something who
come from within that St Olf Community
towns people uh jocks who don't want to
be in a three hour thre hour a week
rehearsal um five bated cappers who
don't match pitch you know um one woman
said I feel like a failure I'm at St ol
college and I can't sing you know L she
she later became a road scholar in
saying that you know but they have they
come together and they have a purpose
and they have a reason for being and I
also direct a boys group out of the
Northfield youth course and when I came
there I had come from very fine program
I had in Michigan and I said to the
founder well how do you decide I
actually use the word how do you
audition them in and she looked at me
her name was cor Schultz she looked at
me like I was crazy and she said if they
breathe and don't destroy the room
they're in deal with
them 24 years I've had that group okay
and those boys have taught me a lot
about reality I love the St Olf choir I
love but those other two groups keep me
grounded and human because they don't
come for the fame they don't come for
whatever they come because coming
together they're better people when they
leave those boys who come and I had the
boys course so I have about 20 to 25 9
through 14 year olds unchanged changing
God knows what's happening to them okay
and the room reeks okay it's Bo big time
and one of the music at students came in
she says it's funky in here I said baby
that is Success okay that is
Success okay but there those little boys
tell me about later sometimes they can
describe it then but they said we can
say things we can sing things that we
can't say we can express our hearts in a
way that's cool and nobody's judging
us okay and so I think and I'm glad you
made that point about Excellence because
I think in the in in the desire that
everyone wants to be inclusive and then
it's like do you dumb
down okay I was raised in a household
that you believed in volunteerism and at
home we had the powdered milk okay but
when we went to church they got the good
good milk okay you gave your very best
for
others the whole idea of volunteer
volunteerism is not about looking down
or the idea even in the coral world when
we talk about amateur and professional
I'm sick and tired of that because Shaw
had it right I think when he talked
about the amateurs being the true lover
of the art okay and if and the thing
that professionals will sometimes lose
is that love of the art and so to be
able to get all of that and why because
you want to love something you're
doing and and I think what I've tried to
do and what I've tried to change over
the years is yeah I'm demanding I won't
let crap go on because that's also
respecting their time they've come to
achieve something and they want to know
that it was worth leaving their house
driving out an icy night to come to you
know your community choir your time
together time to come together you know
um I appreciate so much the the music
therapy uh points this morning my mother
had dementia in her final years and
music was at the end her ability to sing
was the thing that kept her the
medication never
helped but my last visit with her when
she didn't talk for an hour and 15
minutes and I finally took her into her
room and I played a recording happened
to be one of the himym albums that I had
St choir and it was that beautiful saber
that signature piece she had sung that
in the church choir and when the woman
hadn't talked for 75 minutes she started
she was was not a wussy Meto she was a
true contralto she sang that solo she
sang the whole last verse the second
Alto part and then her favorite him was
his eyes on the sparrow and I started
singing that and she sang it with me she
remembered the second verse I couldn't
remember and at the end she looked up at
me but not talking to me for over 75 and
she said baby when'd you get here you
look good somebody's feeling real
feeding you real good these days aren't
they but music okay that communal song
she would sing in the house all the time
so it's not just singing in a choir but
that making music together I think
that's why people come and the
difference is to let people know there
is a reason why they do that that they
belong I I just wanted to say quickly
there actually is an essay called if
Congress was a choir by Margaret Evans
and I would definitely recommend
Googling it and reading it because she
makes wonderful points about
cooperation well another question and uh
I think Molly maybe already hinted at
this a little bit when you talked about
uh well a problem with coral Excellence
uh is when it's when it's used as a way
of alienating or uh excluding um we had
talked about the difference between a
choir singing at an audience or singing
for an audience and like a lot of the
things that we're talking about this
morning that that strikes me as
something that's both
uh undeniably true and and that we know
it when we see it but also kind of hard
to explain so I wonder if if any of you
have any thoughts about what what is the
difference between a choir that sings at
versus a choir that sings for or or what
do those Choirs do um uh to to achieve
that that kind of a connection with the
audience I I I have something I okay
this is um an experiment that that I
wanted to do and it relates to um that
experience I have that I talked about um
singing in quartets but I have this
dream of trying to recre recreate that
experience for the audience and I
thought it I mean maybe it wouldn't work
and it would certainly be terrifying for
the singers but a cool thing to do would
be to disperse um all the singers
throughout the crowd The Voice Parts all
mixed up and I thought it's possible
then that the Audience by having
different voice Parts singing all around
them would experience at least some of
that resonance that I feel singing in
harmony with different voice Parts all
around me it's just an experiment I
would love to try I don't know if if as
conductors that would be something you'd
want to do no we've done it done it well
put the choir around an audience and he
split them up and no literally with no
yeah and and I had to do that one in two
situations a live situation where the
church wasn't big enough so the only way
I could get the choir to sing it was in
Baton rou Louisiana and literally they
were mixed in because that's the only
way I could make it work and what was
the feedback it was good well the kids
were scared you know at first it was
very you know and you couldn't practice
it that way because you could put them
out but they weren't body staring up at
you you know and and you know they would
but it was nice would they want to do it
every night no but was it a an
interesting experience yeah but what was
the feedback from the audience well they
enjoyed hearing it you know unless they
had the loud tener right by
there you know I talk a lot were we
surprised uh I tell my audience a lot
about every piece of music I think
that's really important I also make sure
my singers really know a lot of
information about every song that they
sing
um but talking with the audience is
usually also combined with some element
of audience participation if we do a
South African song um I explain to the
audience that it's really weird it
doesn't feel authentic at all to perform
a South African song for a bunch of
people that are sitting there staring at
you um and so I actually for almost
every piece that I do I make the
audience stand up and I teach them the
movements and have them at least do that
with us and it doesn't compromise it at
all it really does make it feel more
authentic it energizes the singers I
think they're always it's it always
feels like a dare it's always like are
they going to do it and it's amazing
because I actually you know I'm the
conductor I get to turn my back to the
audience in the end and uh I can only
tell by the expression on my singer's
faces and I have to kind of wait and see
what happens too and afterwards they you
know the singers are beaming they're
like every single person was dancing um
there were people in wheelchairs and
they were doing the movements and you
know the the grumpy man in the corner
who looked like he was asleep theat
entire time got up and did the dance
movements and it it really is very
meaningful and I think it is important
um to get the audience feeling like they
play a role in the performance like they
are engaged and like our singers are
singing I mean I really think this
should be a mantra that we are singing
for the people there and not at them
because it's so weird having people sing
music um having these sort of
professional choirs get up and sing
music that you've sung that you have
this intimate connection to and have
them sing it at you and sort of not
acknowledge that you're there um so it's
I think this is a really interesting
thing to think about uh as conductors
for for the future how do we find new
ways of engaging our audiences in our
performances um and again that don't
dumb them down necessarily but that that
make it a more authentic connection
between performer audience member and
the repertoire itself because again we
are not here to just recreate everything
that's been done before us we are not
here to study and be okay I have to do
this and that and this and that great
I've done my perfect Bak performance we
are here to Breathe new life into this
music to bring new meaning to this music
to figure out why do we still sing these
songs that have existed for hundreds of
years why do they still move us and
touch us and that is really what our
what our job is not just as conductors
but as singers as well so yeah I would
agree great program notes but sometimes
just to hear a verbal explanation I also
don't want to go to a concert and I've
been hearing a lot of where the
conductor feels like they're the MC up
there no so but but that that's the
other side of it but I think to give
some insight sometimes I deconstructed a
piece in front of an audience so
especially it's a weird piece think
peski stop at Ma one where you don't
hear you know but what are you listening
for otherwise you hear just these sounds
coming at you right but I think it's
also an attitude okay it's an attitude
um what I guess I'm looking for in
whatever age whatever type is there an
honesty in the
singing because I think you can work
Perfection to one degree when we lose
almost in
honesty and and is that part of the
spirit that is moving and is that part
of what um and I think you can stand on
risers and sing at a a sing to an
audience and with an audience and for an
audience I you know I think the things
that you're suggesting is great
sometimes it's not always possible but I
think how moving um sometimes we've had
I still remember a performance in Miami
at the acda of this wonderful Children's
Chorus from Houston not a community
choir I'm not I've conducted I conducted
a community choir but this was an
elementary school choir some of you may
know the name of Mariana Simpson and you
know most of our children's chir
enforcing in this country are about
two-third girls oneir
boys okay that's you you're lucky yeah
okay okay so here I saw a choir that was
at at least half boys if not more it was
every shade of the rainbow and the
singing was very beautiful okay but
there was just an honesty in the what
they sang and how they sang it and I
have never been so moved in a long time
by that and I later went the next year I
was in Houston to do do Festival I said
I want to go to this school because I
thought maybe this was a charter school
Magnet School well she was in a very
middle class school she had I walked in
the beginning of the building it was
very nice I walked all the way to the
back of the building building where she
was in the cinder block sort of
construction thing and it was butt ugly
room but those children walked in and
they be it became magic and I saw a
teacher I saw a teacher take and when
when they started singing they knew it
wasn't perfect at first but they knew
what they were striving for that was one
of the few choirs I've ever seen used to
Cur and hand signals and really ajust
pitch really ajust pitch okay but what
more when we got there and maybe the
last piece I always always remember was
singing I am his child Moses Hogan and
before they sang it each kid started
telling me something about Moses Moses
was one of my closest
friends before they started to sing they
had me in tears because they knew about
him or how this music started to relate
to
them and the same way you describe the
motets with the kids they had made that
their piece so I think part of the
exercise and long-winded answer is this
to say how do we help our singers to
take ownership of the music not just
what we impart but I'm asking more
questions than I did 15 years ago what
does this mean to you I can give a
certain point but what does it mean to
you because and we have an exercise with
the choir that I direct the S choir that
PR every concert we have what we call
devotions they're not necessarily
spiritual things but they talk about
what the music means to them and all of
a sudden you started hearing this kid
who you thought was totally like I this
piece sucks that's the way they've
looked every time I've conducted it okay
yet that's the piece they decided to
talk about and it's hitting them you
don't know who you're going to touch
it's not talking to the audience I'm
talking within us it needs to start here
in in that group and then then we have
something to share I'm I'm glad you
mentioned that because you that was also
of course part of my experience at
Concordia we called them divos and and
often it's not religious and the Glee
Club uh before I came here they also had
uh same tradition they just call it pep
talks and and it really is it's about
establishing the intent right before you
sing and I think that's incredibly
important that just that last because we
there's so many
distractions uh and I sometimes I I
wonder what it must have been like to be
the conductor of a choir like let's say
150 years ago before the dawn of
recorded music let alone the internet
but recorded music how special that
experience must have been when a choir
was gathered on stage and then the AUD a
showed up and you actually got to hear
the Mozart re I mean that was an event I
don't think anybody in that room at that
time would had to be reminded Hey listen
this is special there's something
special that's going to happen they all
would have known that instinctively just
because of you know the way life was at
that time now now today we take it for
granted that we can hear the most
beautiful performance of any given
Masterwork any with the click of a
button and so to recreate that sense
that what we're doing right now is very
special I I think is a unique challenge
to conductors in the 21st century but
but but so then what can you do well it
comes down to those simple things you
can have a pep talk you can have a
member of the choir stand up before you
go on and say hey everybody just a
little reminder I love this choir and I
love this piece that we're singing and
this is really special and and uh you
just reminded me of another thing that I
I always try to remember to say to the
group uh at the beginning of a tour I I
think you said something like well you
never know who you're going to connect
with in the audience uh I always try to
remember to to say uh because on a tour
you never know you might have a packed
house or then one night there's only 10
people there and that can be a very
deflating experience you walk out on the
stage and suddenly you think oh well I
guess this concert doesn't matter but
what I try to remember to tell the group
before that happens before they see an
audience of 10 people is that that
really doesn't matter because you could
be singing for a thousand people and
maybe they're all distracted by their
cell phones or whatever and none of them
has a transformative experience or you
could sing for 10 people and five of
them are deeply moved and are changed by
what they heard that would be the far
more meaningful performance and you just
never know I also find sometimes in
rehearsal these days they don't always
want to just hear from me so maybe I
bring a conduct student conductor up to
conduct the same piece but they do it
they react differently it's been very
humbling uh it's been very insightful
you know sometimes it's not the greatest
gesture but they just do something that
the kids respond to or when we're
looking at a piece that's the nice thing
about the in the academy you know I have
a text I got kids who are English Majors
who you know or you know they have this
insight and an environmental piece and
they can bring this and all of a sudden
they start contributing to the teaching
and that's been slow on me coming to do
I will admit it but where I don't have
to be the the full Fountain of Knowledge
for that that group and for them you
know maybe if you're doing choirs of
Faith you you're not always the one
doing the ex Jesus of the text somebody
else can do that um we were doing James
AG uh text at one point um it wasn't
sure in the sh I was something else I'm
trying but but a student had just been
studying in in their class and they came
in and the perspective they could
provide so I think it's it's
releasing type A personality releasing
control
and trusting and enabling those folks to
have have a say in the music making of
what
happens also just one quick last thought
I think it's really important that we
expand who we sing for and I know Andre
brought this up earlier but who are we
bringing our music to and you know
there's this sense that like you're
supposed to perform for whatever your
appropriate audiences are and I'm lucky
that I work with a children's choir um
two University choir s Adult choirs um
so I get this full range but I realize
that I get locked into the expectations
of well what audiences do each of those
choirs perform for and I'm not sure why
we don't break that down more um getting
to bring college students to perform at
a school for five-year-olds and interact
with them certainly would be a really
magical experience I had a bunch of my
teenagers on tour recently and we took
them to a preschool and one of the one
of the most one of the most powerful
moments in my life as a singer was when
I was growing up I got to go on tour to
South Africa and perform right after the
first Democratic elections it was a very
very uh powerful time and we performed
for school children and uh we started to
sing a song and they came up to us on
the stage and reached their hands out to
us and brought us down off the stage
into the audience and we danced and sang
together and that was just I mean
mindblowing I couldn't understand how
you could cross the barrier between
performer on the risers and people in
the the audience and all make music
together organically in that way and I I
I try to remember that experience as
much as I can and and try to challenge
myself to create that in any way I can
and so recently I brought a bunch of
teenagers to a preschool and had them uh
after singing a bunch of songs on stage
they came and surrounded the little kids
and we I kept asking them questions so
you ask 5-year-olds questions you get
8,000 answers and this one little boy
who had learned very wisely that he
should just be the loudest um in the
audience he said I don't sing and I was
like okay well we're going to try and uh
we we taught them a song I had my
teenagers sing very simple song Bring me
little water Sylvie and teach the
five-year-olds and each of my teenagers
got on their knees and knelt and put
their arms around two five-year-olds and
sang the song with the 5-year-olds over
and over and over again until they then
could break into Harmony and the kids'
eyes were all wide and they couldn't
believe they were hearing Harmony around
them and they kept singing the melody
and at the end the same little
5-year-old goes I am now going to sing
for the whole rest of my
life
and but then I asked myself why don't I
bring my college students to do that why
don't I bring my adult choirs to do that
you know we have these expectations and
I think we need to start challenging
ourselves to to broaden who we perform
for who we bring this music to and which
of our ensembles we do that with well
can I can I make that less of a torical
question I why because uh I'm definitely
guilty of that I think my groups tend to
perform for their expected audiences
occasionally we do not but definitely
most of the time that we do uh friends
family coal music
enthusiasts uh you know that that kind
of thing uh so is it and I don't know
maybe somebody in the audience has an
idea you could yell it out uh what why
don't is it just is it laziness or is it
fear or are we uh just kind of so you
know just a little bit too locked into
uh this the safety net of what we're
comfortable with or because it seems
almost self-evident that we would all
want that right right what we would love
that's kind of a dream like let have my
choir sing for a group of people who've
never heard that kind of music before
and and who get to hear it for the first
time we would all want that I think it's
I think it's practical things but I
think we all need to just commit to
overcoming them scheduling is hard hard
it's hard to take people out of work or
out of the school day to perform at a
school we also inherit programs where
there are set performances that we're
expected to do and so we just fall into
the habit of doing them since they're
already laid out but it's certainly
something worth uh rethinking and and a
thing we should commit to to try to do
it differently we had an experience
about a year ago two years ago I guess
now and someone had a gentleman who's
trying to develop a network and is still
in the process um
the basic point was as ARP is able to be
a big group and represent uh uh people
of a certain age group and they have
more bargaining power uh because it is a
ARP this man is dealing with special
needs child and he said you know you
have if you have an autistic child
you're dealing this if you have this
type of child you're dealing this he's
trying to build this network so he's
trying to create a piece to to use as a
selling point but he came he didn't
really know anything about uh St Olf but
he had some somebody finally showed him
a one of the Christmas programs or
something and what ended up being was
the St choir and St Orchestra being part
of this this video well for the kids it
meant doing this but all of a sudden
what part of the thing was that the kids
went in and they sang and they orchest
had to stay on stage but the choir went
in amongst the families and some in
wheelchairs some children who had tette
syndrome and and everything but all of a
sudden the kids were just arms around on
the kids or some one little girl just
jumped in the arms of one of the boys
and he just sang to her and I mean I
don't know where this is going to come
out but it was an experience that
started to makeing me to
think yeah it is when you get in the
academy it's easy to say something like
this it is harder to make happen in
certain things but if you're more
intentional and then there's been a
subsequent project in which we were and
it's it's slowly breaking the mold down
um I guess one thing I'm going to say to
all of you none of us is sitting up here
like we have the
answers you in a way what he's asking us
to do is share our journey and the
journeys and our stumbles and our
missteps or our apprehensions but I
guess you know we're we're kind
of being naked with you right now and
it's not always pretty but um uh but I
think these questions were about asking
us and then maybe asking you all the
same things you know how can you maybe
shift your Paradigm of of what of what
you do and I think it is a struggle at
times and especially if you have certain
certain ways that you've always done it
and how do you shift out personally and
then how do you get an organization to
believe that they should be shifting as
well so I think it has to be a process a
journey well here's something a little
bit different um as conductors and and
singers uh of coral music we're
obviously working a lot with religious
music um and often that's music from one
specific religion religious tradition uh
and yet I think we could probably all
agree that singers and audiences can
connect with that repertoire whether or
not that piece is from their own
religious tradition right uh what what
does that say about the experience of
group
singing I have a lot to say about
this um and part of it is that I see so
many instances lately of conductors um
colleagues calling me not knowing what
to do about the fact that they have
singers who have decided they will not
sing a certain piece on the program and
uh it it's become this sort of epidemic
of singers cherry-picking which pieces
they'll sing and which they won't and it
doesn't look particularly great to have
students suddenly leave the stage for
certain songs um and I started really
engaging with a lot of my colleagues
about these issues and it made me
realize that my own Journey has been
quite interesting in coming around to
how do I deal with singing religious
music I grew up a very non-religious Jew
um and realized that a lot of the music
that I spent most of my time listening
to was palestrina and bah and um and
singing as well and and that this music
captured my soul more deeply than
anything in the world when I was 12 I
had to choose between staying in choir
or having a bot Mitzvah because Hebrew
school was at the same time as choir
rehearsals and I went to my Rabbi and he
said to me well where do you feel a
stronger sense of spirituality and
connection to the community and I said
oh that's easy choir and he said well
then you better go sing and in a way
that's how music did become my religion
but that wasn't that simple because the
reality was that I was spending a lot of
my time singing music that not only
wasn't of my own faith but that I really
didn't believe the lyrics too at all and
I had issues with a lot of the lyrics
and I I asked people how do I deal with
this and at times when I was growing up
in my choir um there were a few other
kids who were non-Christian but there
were also times where I was the only
non-Christian in The Ensemble and of
like a hundred kids so I really had to
think about what that meant um
and the advice that I was given which I
still hear people give singers all the
time uh which I now really don't believe
in is oh well pretend you're singing
about something else when you're singing
about Jesus pretend you're singing about
something you do believe in pretend
you're singing about something else you
love whether it's you know sing about
your own God I don't believe in God uh
sing about your dog you know what I'm
like really I'm singing palestrina about
my dog I don't even have a dog anyway so
but you know I was like this is not this
isn't working for me um and then I
started to really reflect on what it
meant to sing my own experience growing
up the things that had mattered most to
me were that my the choir that I sang
with growing up was Multicultural um we
had kids from all different races all
different religious backgrounds and all
different socioeconomic backgrounds um
and that in itself was really
interesting and one of the most powerful
experiences was coming to choir and
realizing that we were going to sing a
Hanukkah Song on this one concert and
watching all of these kids who were not
Jewish singing this music from my
religion and not just singing it but
working really hard to sing it
excellently working really hard to get
the notes to feel what the piece was
about to sing it you know create these
beautiful harmonies and use all of the
all of the techniques that they had been
taught to to bring Beauty to this piece
of music that was supposedly mine and
didn't belong to any of them and that
was really magical and suddenly I
realized wow I love this that the like
little Japanese kid is singing the solo
on the Irish song and that the
African-American girl is singing the
solo on the max chanowski you know
Hebrew piece and that uh you have like
the kid those poor little white kid who
can't barely step and clap and is trying
with all his might to sing the gospel
song and I suddenly realized that these
were the acts that really and truly
created community in the coral world and
in fact I mean I'm bringing this around
again to the idea of how Coral music
music should be a challenge striving for
excellence should be a part of it and
it's what should make it more accessible
because what I've realized is that in
fact the most beautiful poignant moments
of coral music making for me is when I
make the choice to sing lyrics that I
don't believe in because in so doing I'm
not lying to myself or to an audience
but I'm taking a part of myself s and my
own identity and making less important
than it is to acknowledge through music
making how important it is that the
person standing next to me who believes
in those lyrics belongs in my community
and so in singing singing words I don't
believe in I'm affirming that this
person standing next to me who believes
in in Christianity or whatever it is
that we're singing that that person
belongs and that they are my community
and if that challenge didn't exist it
wouldn't would be as meaningful really
and so I try to talk to my students
about this and I say to them oh you
don't believe in this song interesting
what does it mean for you to sing it and
they sort of blink at me and I say to
the person sitting next to them who does
believe in the song what does it mean
for you when she sings this song and
they say oh well it's it's so nice of
you that you're willing to like take the
time and effort to learn music from my
tradition and and sing this for me and I
started to realize also then it affirmed
to me how important it is again that we
use excellence in doing this because
when we when we work hard to do the
music of another culture or other people
when we work hard to do it well we're
saying that those people have value to
us and have meaning and belong and are
worth are worth just as much effort as
bak and Mozart and that is so important
um and so I challenge people nowadays
conductors who are struggling with this
um not to tell someone to imagine that
they're singing a about their dog when
they're singing palestrina but to think
about what it might mean to someone else
in the room who believes in these things
now obviously there are challenges that
go beyond that it's very different to
ask someone who is a minority to sing
the music of the majority to sing the
culture of powers music versus the other
way around but you'll often find that
it's the majority who resists singing
music from other cultures and not the
other way around and that if you provide
enough support and dialogue and
experience for the singers to talk about
what it means to them you can make
minorities more comfortable as well
singing things they don't believe in but
really that is the greatest way that we
can use Coral music to create Community
is through through taking that challenge
and learning how to how to give up your
own identity for a moment to affirm the
importance of others in our
group that was really beautifully
explained thank
you
[Applause]
do you want to comment this you want to
do this and no you got into this in our
phone conversation I yeah I just that
was just so well put
um for me I I'm also agnostic so when I
first joined a choir it quite honestly
it did feel really weird at first to me
singing this music because I'm the kind
of person where if I'm with a group and
they start to say the Lord's Prayer I
won't recite it along with them not out
of disrespect but I feel like I'm being
dishonest and I just don't feel like
it's the right thing to do but I I don't
you know I don't think that weird
feeling I felt that that first rehearsal
lasted the length of the rehearsal
there's something about Sacred Music
sacred words put set to music that
touches me and reaches me in a way
that words alone do not and I no longer
feel like I'm lying when I sing those
words and I can't explain it but I know
in my heart of hearts it's true so I do
think about it a lot and I I actually I
wrote a chapter trying to compare what I
felt singing this piece of music by
Victoria that I love and how it felt for
the very first P very first people to
have sung this music you know how do our
feelings compare and the first group of
people to sing that piece of music was
were probably as far as me from me as
you could possibly get it was a group of
young German Seminary students in the
16th century and so I looked at all the
stuff that I was learning about music
and what it does to us and I thought
about the fact that you know they have a
body I have a body so it's got to be you
know
physiologically um affecting us the same
way and I focused in particular on this
one piece of um science that I learned
um that just felt relevant to me it was
in Daniel leviton's book uh this is your
brain on music and he talked about the
fact that um the the mirror um mirror
excuse me the brain I want to make sure
I get this right pitch is literally
literally mirrored in the brain and if
you put electrodes on someone's brain
you could tell what pitch they're
singing just by looking at the activity
in the brain and so I immediately
thought well does that mean I don't know
but does that mean that um when I'm
singing in harmony with someone else
that that harmonic interval is again
literally not figuratively being
mirrored in both our brains and so our
our bodies our brains have evolved so
that singing in harmony feels really
really good and what does that mean I
mean if you believe in God God made us
this way if you believe in evolution we
evolve this way to to have something
that involves cooperation feel so so
good and there's this wonderful quote
from handle I'm just going to have to
paraphrase but somebody gave was
complimenting him about the Messiah and
he said um uh well I would be sorry if I
only entertain them I wanted to make
them better and I think singing does
make us better regardless of belief so
when a great artist um writes um intense
um intensely Spiritual music to
accompany lines like may angels lead you
into paradise and when I sing that line
regardless of my beliefs that I feel
that deep deeply in in that intent that
that deeply felt hope you know resonates
through my body and I believe it does
make me better and when I'm singing like
that I am not thinking about like who
around me believes what and I'd be
shocked if anybody
did I want to just take a small point
and and say
that part of so most of you know the
choir is the I do is primarily not
exclusively but primarily of a Christian
background but there are a lot of kids
who sing in this choir that are uh on
faith Journeys or they don't know what
they want to do this was a note I got
two weeks ago from a student
um I thought a lot on the drive home
about the impact that you and the choir
have had on me over these past two years
I don't know if you are aware but I was
not raised in a very religious home and
when I auditioned for the S of choir I
was nervous about not fitting in or
understanding the spirit spiritual
aspect of music making they had done a I
programmed a piece by one of our
students who was graduating a setting of
Psalm 46 she said as I was singing
present help in trouble yesterday I was
so moved by the text remind her that
this infinite Creator whatever we call
it is with us at the break of day and
through the night was an incredibly
comforting thought the knowledge that
God or whatever you're going to call it
is with us when we have found peace as
well as when we are suffering is
something I had heard time
I had a hard time understanding before I
found a new sense of Peace Within Myself
this weekend through concerts but
especially Zach's piece I wish I had a
better language to talk about what I
have been feeling in our rehearsals and
performances recently but I hope I'm at
least communicating fragment of the
relief and comfort I'm finding in being
a member of this group and and and for
me it's not whether you believe in Jesus
Christ or whatever but I think this is
why I keep talking about people
belonging I just came back on Saturday
from Korea um I'm still fighting jet lag
and I haven't yawned yet okay but I'm
doing bot f with this Korean choir and
about half of them were not people
certainly not Christians and not people
of any faith but there's a message in
there be not afraid I'm with you you
know I've called you by your name dubis
mine you are mine and I try to explain
that not that they had to believe I
wanted them to understand because here
Korean singing German what what is the
intent of the composer what is the mind
of the composer do you agree or what but
they that was the piece they would stop
in their broken English much better than
my non-existent Korean and say to me
thank you it was a hard piece we had to
work for all the Excellence and all
things but all of a sudden this is a
culture that believes in family it
believes in people being together and
all of a sudden this Bond of what they
respect and what they admire they found
in this German composer of 300 400 years
ago and I think that's when we cross the
boundaries of uh of time and space of
ethnicity of religiosity of political
bonds I mean that's why you can have a
choir in which you might be this point
politically and that point politically
but you find the common ground in
humanity and I think whether it's you we
were talking about religious music but I
think this talks about anything people
want to belong people want to feel like
they they are
known they are known in some way and I
think the music that that we do needs to
be able to touch that body mind spirit
and
voice and and you don't necessarily I'm
not trying to say somebody should be
converted in a way but the fact that she
couldn't even feel and part of what she
later said in the subsequent message
when I said thank you she
said I'm real uptight this this helps
you to understand my uptightness because
sometimes I don't believe that other
than my parents anybody cares about me
and in this music making and in this
group I found people who care and I
found a message and I don't know yet if
I believe in God but I believe that
something is coming at me that says I
have value I have worth if anything in
my own students in the you know 15 or so
years I've been I've been teaching
college students uh you know they've
probably become even more religiously
diverse and you know there was that Pew
study that came out just recently I
think that basically you know all
religious identification in the United
States across all groups pretty much is
gone down except across the group that
says they have no religion which which
has increased and but but it is not the
case that my students my Millennial
religiously diverse students are less
interested in Sacred Music if anything I
I would say that they're a little bit
more interested than they were uh a
dozen or so years ago and you could be
cynical about that I think and say that
that's maybe kind of a
shallow uh desire for some kind of
authenticity City like like a Brooklyn
Hipster who is pickling their own
vegetables you know it kind of feels
feels like something real but I think
that would be misguided I I don't think
that's the case I I think that it is a
like in this reality TV culture that we
live in when they recognize that this is
a you know piece of art that at least
was making a sincere attempt to get at
something larger and get at a larger
truth that that speaks to them whether
or not that's their own religious
tradition well and it helps you to try
to un for non-religious people singing
Sacred Music helps you try to feel
connected and understand religious
people which is yeah which is really
essential that's another border that we
need to cross yeah well all right so we
have I hope there are a couple of
questions we have about I don't know
seven or eight minutes but uh before
before I uh invite you to ask your own
questions I think I I skipped one
question I I hope that's okay but I want
to come to our last question maybe sort
of as a lightning round round if you can
each give us an
answer in like 20 words or so
uh okay let's try let's try this uh why
do the singers in your choirs keep
showing
up I I'll go okay thank you sty I I have
another quote um but this was a 19 C uh
music credit and he said in no other art
are amateurs privileged to enjoy the
spiritual beauties of a creation to the
degree that music offers to corers so
unlike going into a museum and looking
at a great painting or even making a
fairly good copy of a great painting
when you sing a work of art you're
channeling that work of art um through
your body it feels really really good
and a member of my choir put it best she
said you get to ride on the genius of a
Beethoven or a
palestrina and as I said feels really
good I'll come back for
that well I'm simply I think people
people are looking
for a sense of belonging let me just re
they want to be part of something they
they they they also want to come back to
a place
where a younger generation which wants
instant access to everything because of
this stuff in music there you you you
articulated so beautifully before but
you hit on
this that practice that going after
something we're teaching life lessons
and whether or not they fully understand
it they're getting something they're
getting maybe the first time when
somebody actually says there is
discipline you know we have to have
guidelines not you know you're okay I'm
okay everything's okay no you're not you
can be better but you can be better in a
productive way and you're not being put
down but you're saying how you can be
lifted up and a life lesson in which
you're not life is not the instant
answer okay it's it's it's a journey and
when you progress through that piece and
it may take you three four seven eight
weeks to get that piece when you finally
do maybe it's the first thing you
finally freaking got a cord and tune you
know and it's like thank you Lord
Almighty okay but that's an
achievement and I think I think people
are looking for that type of thing and
something where they can be uplifted but
they can actually achieve something
together when they see politics is not
doing that this is not doing that the
church sometimes doesn't offer that okay
but you can have that you can have
commonality you can have consensus and
you can have something of excellence and
Beauty in a world that's full of
hardship and pain and they can
experience it and feel it every
week
yeah yeah I I agree with all of that is
that sense of you know once I asked I
actually asked my students I I had a i
ranted at them about something they
weren't doing right because I knew they
could they just weren't doing it and
then they did it right and I said why
did you make me take an entire 45
minutes yelling at you before you did it
right you know and they were like I said
why do you even keep coming back here I
you know and they said because you yell
at us because you care and because you
make us do it right and because you
expected that we could do it and we
didn't even believe we could but then we
did and it and it's it's about this
ability to create beauty that no single
person could do on their own but when
they come together they are capable of
something so much greater um that they
don't even know that they're capable of
and if you show them that every
rehearsal oh my God just think of what
we can do in the world and beyond that
also I know that my singers have talked
about the fact that they often feel like
they don't know they don't have the the
resources to show people from different
backgrounds that they respect them and
want to learn about them and honor them
and that through singing music from
different Traditions is one of the most
accessible clear ways that they have
that ability that they can you know I
love it but my favorite is always miss
Stone um over break I went on to I went
away and in the taxi our taxi driver was
from Nigeria and I sang him the Nigerian
song and he cried because he was so
happy and I was like
yay yay you made a taxi driver cry no
but still but I mean just feeling like
they can create connections through
their ability to create music that's
pretty good reason well I certainly have
nothing to add to that you guys nailed
it um uh are there any
questions we back
here oh
here had somebody say um we're going to
do this again but you start
it not not just stop conducting but not
start the piece when you're ready you 70
people right um start start this passage
and to have us listen and think together
to to make that happen and the other
thing um is to use
improvisation um to take four or five
volunteers and say start to sing
something and work together um to make
to make it happen happen um both of
those were were very transformative
experiences thank you maybe just one
more over
here this isn't a
question when you spoke about singing at
or for the audience I'm a very
average at at my best singer but I
always think of singing with the
audience is that they are as much part
of us as we are part of each other um
and
that
Spirit just keeps the US and they them
apart out out of the picture um and the
other thing um as a as a
Cher the the greatest gift that you give
in specifics to to sing well is to as
you said Jeff to not have the focus on
you but to have you be the focuser and
Jeff singing with you you do this
impeccably um is to is to have one thing
that you want us to focus on at that
moment never speak about what we're
doing wrong saying what you would like
us to do quote right unquote and then to
tell us how to do that so that we can
all sing as one and and I learned that a
um conductors conference where I was in
a the choir up in Maine where there were
40 conductors and the the head of the
school just had each person come up and
said is this is your only job is to know
what you want and to ask the chorus to
do that and all the chers a little bit
figure out how to do that so thank you
thank you very much for those thoughts
and thanks so much to my fellow
panelists this is a wonderful
conversation we have to do this again
[Applause]
[Music]
soon and
uh and just quickly before you run to
get a bite to eat I think Stephanie has
an announcement that pertains to the 21c
folks and to the yak volunteers for the
Friday morning project who if they're in
the room they know who they are yes you
know who you are because of all the
emails you've gotten in the last week
and a half um but if you are in those
groups and you have lunch meetings today
um we'll actually be meeting at Wall
Street Pizza um so we'll meet first in
the lobby and we'll walk over together
thank
you I do I have one
somewhere
fine self
[Music]
M welcome back thanks to our third panel
of the day entitled expanding our
reach I'll give
people in the lobby a second to come in
once they heard the
microphone
all right welcome
back to our third panel of the day
entitled expanding our
reach Sebastian Ruth is the founder and
artistic director of Community Music
Works a nationally recognized
organization that works to build Civil
Society in the United States by creating
new roles for musicians to positively
influence American cities since 2013
Sebastian has served as a visiting
lecturer at the Yale School of Music
Micah hendler founder and director of
the YMCA Jerusalem Youth Chorus is a
graduate of yel college in music and
International Studies TJ Harper is
associate professor of music and the
direct director of coral activities and
music education at Providence College in
Providence Rhode Island Emily how is a
conductor music educator and a componist
a faculty member at Boston University's
prison education program hous work
co-designing a music curriculum at the
Framingham women's prison earned her the
distinction of prison Arts scholar
Thomas cabanis composer writes for Opera
theater dance film and the concert stage
he is also active in Creative approaches
to music education and musical
[Applause]
[Music]
engagement thank you
Stephanie uh welcome back from
lunch this is the time of day at a
conference where you your brain has no
blood because all your blood is busy
digesting your lunch and so it's the
time of day where in some parts of the
world we take a
nap and we've just dimmed the lights
that will facilitate your nap
taking
but uh on our panel conference call we
decided that the best way to lead off
would be to show examples uh of our work
Andor some other kinds of show and tell
on the screen so I think you'll find
this so energizing
in that you will stay awake and that at
least by about 2 o' you'll be like oh
yeah I'm awake I'm at a conference this
is great um so uh I I really like the
language that um Jeff and his colleagues
use to describe the topic here um and
that is you know what ties our work
together as you'll see over the next 75
minutes or so um is that we're each
working with populations as as Jeff has
called it um who are maybe outside the
expected Circle uh of constituents for
the kind of music we're working in and
that's if if you're paying attention you
might realize that's a an
intentional uh choice of language that
doesn't use the word
Outreach um and and I think several of
us share in this feeling that Outreach
implies two body of people or
institutions on the one hand you have
the in in the case of most of you the
coral art or the tradition of music and
Outreach might imply that that is just
reaching a helping hand out to someone
with the sort of metaphorical idea that
then they would be bringing them back
and I think there's a different approach
to the work um that many of us take
which is to say the people who are going
to engage in this are very much
the subject and the object of this work
uh and the institution or Traditions you
know that we may be familiar with are
not the priority um the repertoire may
be the priority the approach of pedagogy
um may be the priority where May there
may be Innovation there but in fact
we're trying to create new musical
traditions and new contexts um so that
the music uh that we're working with has
the greatest opportunity for
transformative impact so I really like
this idea of of thinking about people
outside the expected Circle or maybe to
to expand on that metaphor expanding the
the
circle um so we will each take a few
minutes to to introduce some element of
our work and we we all decided there
would be a um snapshot rather than an
overview approach so we'll each take a
moment to give you a snapshot of some
element of our work which will save time
for us to to speak amongst ourselves a
little bit um um obviously for you not
at you um but with this with with the
topic of um uh what is it about work
that we do um that has some similarity
or what are some of the Lessons Learned
what are some of the values behind the
work that may be helpful to others of
you who find some of this inspiring and
might like to venture into some of this
kind of work um and then we'll we'll
save enough time for hopefully a robust
interactive conversation um 20 or 25
minutes at the end so that we can ask
questions of each other and um we'll
expect long lines behind each microphone
because you'll be awake and engaged by
that point in the hour okay so um let me
first welcome Micah uh and his work with
the YMCA Jerusalem youth
course
so this is uh very surreal uh for me
personally um as I just graduated hi um
this very surreal for me personally is I
actually uh
remember just uh doing my DS lectures in
this room uh in
2008 um so or in 2007 actually whatever
anyway it was not that long ago and so
I'm this is kind of meta moment but um
the work that that I do in Jerusalem
obviously is with Israeli and
Palestinian youth the YMCA Jerusalem
Youth Chorus uh should be landing at JFK
around now and uh hopefully you'll all
have a chance to hear them perform and
see really what we're talking about
tomorrow uh but this is a chance also to
get sort of behind the scenes and a
little bit of what actually makes a
chorus like that possible and what kinds
of values and what kinds of uh Community
structures make work like this possible
and how like particularly using
Community singing can facilitate these
kinds of spaces that we were talking
about uh earlier this morning even in a
context of extreme ethnic conflict and
violence um so the only most of my sort
of intro will actually be showing this
music video um but just to give it a
little bit of cont a video that we made
um um with also two friends of mine
actually from The Dukes men from my time
at Yale Ben Wexler who did the
arrangement and Sam shuy who is now a
YouTube Superstar and who will be solo
um basically of this song that talks in
many ways about the journey that our
Israeli and Palestinian teens go through
when deciding to be part of this chorus
um and not
only that maybe it's beautiful or maybe
it's nice but really the hardships also
that they go through through and how
they are there for one another um in
creating a space where they can all feel
at home even in a city that really does
not value that I'll say as a central
principle um so I will just show you the
video and we can talk about it
later will
[Music]
be hold
on to me as we go
As We R
[Music]
down although this
W is stringing us
along just know you're not
alone I'm
going your
home
settle
down it'll all be
[Music]
clear demons they
fear trouble it might drag you
down if you're lost you can always be
found you're not
alone going to make this place your
[Music]
home
settle
down it'll all be clear
[Music]
Toons
fear trouble it might drag you down if
you're lost you can always be
found just know you're not
alone cuz I'm going to make this place
your
[Music]
home oh
oh heart
[Music]
o
[Applause]
e
so are you
awake um what a beautiful way to start
um
Emily uh you heard the introduction so I
will just ceue up her presentation and
get out of the way
Emily
thank you very much and thank you for
getting us off to a great start Micah
that was really
inspiring we heard a little bit this
morning from Andre de quadros about work
that he and I along with our colleague
Jamie Hillman have been have been doing
in two prisons west of Boston in
Framingham and norfol I'm going to talk
a bit more in detail about those
experiences and and focus really on two
spefic specific examples that
contextualize our work and I think give
voice to some of the challenges of
expanding our reach as this panel is
called
life for those of us who have had
positive experiences making music in and
as Community Music is life affirming
possibly even lifechanging but during
this panel we're not talking about
musical lifers such as ourselves rather
we're acknowledging the those people we
have alienated and excluded and asking
how we might democratize the music
making process and learn from the voices
of those who have previously been
marginalized what does it mean to go
beyond what we know what does it mean to
embrace people with sound and with
singing what tools do we have as
conductors and what tools do we need to
develop in order to bring empowering
creative experiences to the people who
arguably need them
most which takes us to prison an
environment very much apart from my own
life and removed from my own admittedly
privileged life
experiences as one student told us
prison is a mind graveyard it is where
your body soul and mind go to
perish prison as I have experienced it
is a strange ecosystem marked by visual
indicators of power and seemingly
arbitrary oral cues that dictate where
inmates need to be and when
as another student wrote it is so easy
here to lose yourself in order not to
have to face whatever Darkness brought
you
here as foreign as it is to me I have
also learned that prison is disturbingly
familiar to many of the people with whom
we work I recognized this for the first
time when talking to a student in the
Men's prison you work in the women's
prison he asked I nodded an affirmation
how is it there I told him that it
seemed okay different from the Men's
prison which by the way is modeled after
Harvard
um true story true
[Laughter]
story the architect was inspired by the
Harvard campus and decided to create a
prison a prison
yes uh so so I said that the women's
prison is a bit green Greener possibly a
bit more comfortable uh he continue to
ask questions how's the food he finally
asked I laughed and told him honestly
that I had no idea
I asked him why he wanted to know how
the food was in the Framingham women's
prison and he said well my mom's going
there I said oh she's visiting she's
visiting someone and he said no no no
she's she's being transferred from her
prison in California new prison framing
him people talk about the cycle of
poverty but I have learned that
incarceration is also a cycle and many
of the people with whom we work also
have parents siblings and children who
are serving
time
and here are the Bleak statistics prison
is not a community Benjamin Harbert who
who writes on music and incarceration in
fact theorizes it as a non-community but
the incarceration epidemic in this
country disproportionately affects
certain communities poor communities
minority communities communities that on
the whole we are not reaching with our
art Coral
music and so we must ask ourselves how
can we use music to build a bridge from
the outside to the inside to challenge
people to re-evaluate themselves as
human beings endowed with the capacity
to
create this morning Andre shared some
features of a pedagog pedagogical
approach we have developed and have come
to call empowering
song uh as he mentioned we treat music
as a bridge to personal exploration and
also through the inclusion of guest
artists from around the nation and the
world as a bridge to the outside
we deal not only with music but with
issues of identity and the facilitation
of personal and communal growth we try
to destabilize the prison environment by
encouraging people to hold hands which
as Andre mentioned not okay in prison we
hold hands we dance we sing and we
question
authority in our class there are no
Spectators only in the words of austo
boal spect actors who are engaged in the
creative process and in a place where
Conformity is not only demanded by the
administration but as we heard from one
of the prisoners adopted as a coping
mechanism we encourage people to reclaim
their individuality and to lift one
another up as
artists our goal is process not product
and we are very upfront with our
students that we are not training them
for the Met nor are we training them for
American Idol we are helping one another
to realize our creative
potential
Andre described some of the context and
setting once again we are working within
the Boston University prison education
program we teach in the Norfolk Men's
prison we have about 20 students there
in any given semester and the Framingham
women's prison where we have around 10
to 15 we work with a lot of people of
different ages our classes range from
age 25 to 65 various races various
ethnic ethnicities and varying sentence
lengths and few of our students in
either setting have had prior musical
training which once again is why we're
here talking about how we can change
that I want to share a a few
representative examples of the kinds of
work that we have done which again spans
from visual work to theater to
poetry we tend to work with a theme each
semester that is drawn from the
repertoire that we work on this was
inspired by the words I once was lost
but now in found which of course come
from the song Amazing Grace and this was
in the women's prison we had the help of
a of a visual artist named sidewalk Sam
who encouraged each student to create
their own kind of Patchwork in this
quilt that kind of depicts their own
identities this you see is hand painted
using Q-tips and magic marker this is an
image painted by a man who is inspired
by the words and neither have eye WIS to
fly which of course comes from the song
um the water is wide neither have I
Wings a fly give me a boat that can
carry two so this is the image of that
vot so we come back to this word life
and I want to share an example of one
particular performance experience that
we had together um we cannot bring
recording equipment into the prison um
so I can't share any video images but
but I'll tell this story Judith Braha
professor of theater and guest
collaborator was facilitating small
group improvisations in our class one
game she introduced is called a kiss a
word a song in this game each skit
features one kiss one word and one song
the rest of the action is pantomimed in
rehearsal everyone was having fun
laughing working well together but when
we shared while two skits were playful
the final skit was very different from
the others the women had arranged
themselves as if in a courtroom one
woman I'll call her Carol was on trial
there was one judge and the other women
were watching the proceedings the judge
sat with furrowed brow Consulting
imaginary notes until finally picking up
an imaginary gavel
life the women watching the trial all
blew dismissive kisses toward Carol and
walked away leaving Carol alone on the
stand looking up from tears she sang
DA's lament remember me but a forget my
fate when Carol finished singing the
room was
silent was that an empowering experience
Carol told us that it was reliving her
own sentencing in the context of a
performance piece helped her to process
her life
sentence this was not the case for
everyone in the class however there were
other women who were also serving life
sentences who did not
appreciate reliving that experience in a
group
context so the question is how do we as
conductors and Educators respond to
these ambiguous challenging and even
divisive moments I would suggest that
nothing in our training prepares us for
these kinds of experiences and so part
of our own work as conductors attempting
to expand our reach has to be to
re-evaluate our own practices to engage
with other people who are doing similar
work thank you for this conference um
and to continue striving for best
processes not best products I'll close
with the voices of a few
students one woman wrote that coming to
class is like shedding the coat of
Despair the aura is bright and I feel
like I can express myself without being
judged another wrote that for 2 and 1
half hours a week I watch a group of
women be themselves let their hair down
and possibly show their softer sides I
see them what they may be like Beyond
these walls they take off their
armors this was also inspired by the
words and neither have I wings to fly
and the student wrote that be has given
me wings through music so I think there
are there are many possibilities here
and I'm excited that we are all working
to realize them thank
[Applause]
[Music]
you
TJ so in line with acda statement on
advocacy the a international conductors
Exchange program our I was launched in
2010 as a means to build meaningful
relationships with cor communities from
around the world as well as providing
international opportunities for the next
generation of leaders in our
profession I think start that's fine
that's
fine ICP is part of a renewed Focus for
ACD on how Coral music has the potential
to reach beyond our borders to have a
positive impact on communities outside
of the United States following the 2016
exchange this program will boast 90
alumni worldwide who have participated
in one toone exchanges that are forging
stronger relationships as builds Bridges
between individuals and communities in
2012 we launched our first Exchange
program with Cuba um with a total of 14
conductors seven from the United States
and seven from Cuba 2014 our exchange
with China engaged a total of 20
conductors this year our exchange with
Sweden engages 28 conductors and next
year our exchange with South Korea will
engage another 28 conductors 14 from the
United States and 14 from Korea these
onetoone exchanges have served as a
catalyst for ongoing sustained
opportunities for growth and a sharing
of knowledge that transcend National
borders ideologies and religions you
know when we started this we had a
planning meeting uh Sebastian uh gave us
all a prompt in addition to the prompt
from Jeff about what this panel
discussion on expanding our reach really
could uh encapsulate and one of the
prompts from Sebastian was to think of a
story on what it means to us to expand
our reach as Professionals in this field
and I couldn't help but think of my own
story as a Kina adopti and uhu maybe as
an unattended consequence of that I felt
the need to always belong somewhere
using Anton's expression and this need
to belong was very powerful and so Coral
music was was an obvious fit for me and
so being in South Korea a few years ago
on a research Grant I found myself
really uh overcome with emotion I found
myself really thinking that these
unintended consequences of of this
experience in my life um were having a
profound impact on what it is that I do
and I think we know as Coral musicians
anytime we come together to create
something of beauty that didn't exist
before we're we're actually contributing
to the common
good and this is something that I think
is very powerful Smith the 18th century
political Economist talks about um um
unintended consequences but in a
positive aspect he talks about the
invisible hand and how when we come
together and we try and do something for
ourselves we actually end up
contributing to the greater good um and
I think this is a powerful statement
this is something that the international
conductors Exchange program uh as a
platform this is something that I think
Tim Shar believes in greatly this is why
he uh was so strongly for this
Recreation of this program but I think
that one of the things that also happens
is that we find ourselves able to create
new directions for connections and so we
have these different things that are
going on we have H A North Dakota
Symposium on International music that
happened last year this last week acda
hosted the second um Latin American
Music Symposium in Austin
Texas in San Juan uh Argentina in
November there will be a forum of
leadership from throughout Latin America
South and Central America to talk about
the direction of coral music um in this
part of the world and somehow our
conductors from the China exchange and
the Sweda Sweden exchange got together
and decided to create their own Exchange
program which I think is outstanding and
so these unintended consequences these
these things that are ultimately
contributing to the common good I think
are powerful so this advocacy statement
by acda and Tim sharp they've created
the platform and now the program is
going off in New
Directions so I'm excited this idea
about belonging is powerful to me it's
powerful I think to all of us and it
enables us to cross these distances
whether it's from choir to choir state
to state um across oceans uh maybe even
from the soprano 1 Section to the
soprano 2 Section so this is exciting um
work and this is an exciting time for
our profession thank
you
so I'm
next I um anyone familiar with the
pakata the tradition uh of showand tell
in Japan where you get 20 slides 20
seconds per slide that's about what I'm
going to do here I'm going to whip
through a set of slides um I'm uh GNA
try to share with you a particular
project that Community Music Works uh
did a few years ago as a way of giving
you a snapshot into our thinking and
some of the issues and problems um
inheriting our work this is an image of
our headquarters in Providence Rhode
Island um this is in the west side of
Providence which um is a complex
neighborhood a lot of um diverse lot of
diversity socioeconomically also
racially and culturally um and our our
mission has always been to have a
professional Ensemble chamber Ensemble
this is strings I'm one of the outliers
here this is not about singing um that
uh that lives and works in the context
of an urban neighborhood with the idea
that we are um uh having a reciprocal
relation relationship with the young
people and adults in the neighborhood
around us at one level we're practicing
the thing that we were trained to do
which is chamber music um at another
level we are not trying to just have a
fixed tradition but really a kind of
movable evolving tradition and we're
trying to through these PL glass windows
as a metaphor really learn from the
musical and cultural traditions of
people in our
neighborhood um that's a um easier to
say than to do and so a couple years ago
so we commissioned a piece recognizing
that over 60% of our students um or from
Latin American families Latin American
backgrounds started to um commission a
piece from uh a Venezuelan composer
Gonzalo grow uh to bring together um
salsa and other Latin music Traditions
with a classical music format um with
our students as part of the orchestra
our professional Ensemble as part of the
orchestra and a professional salsa band
and violin soloist as the other pieces
uh what it the the the moral of the
story is just about how that we um not
only did the project in the kind of
snapshot moment of the performance but
but the work that we tried to do to lead
up to it so this is a an image of
sharing the work after it had just been
written showing excerpts to the students
they could start to get into it similar
here getting groups of students together
to just study the score and start to see
what was involved and then at six months
ahead of time we pulled together a group
that we called our Latino advisory
committee um a couple of my colleagues
are Latino themselves but importantly it
was this was a question of how are we
connecting with latino leaders in our
community to make this a project that
connected on many levels not only um
musically and that also ensured that by
the time the the concert happened we had
um made it a kind of community Festival
Community celebration and so this is a
couple of politicians who hosted a house
uh party um in their
home the hard work got going of
individual ual lessons to study the
score and and uh learn the piece um as
many of you know who work with young
people commissioning is very exciting
but it's also somewhat daunting because
um they don't have anything to fall back
on in terms of a YouTube recording or
any other recording this is you know
fresh out of the gates um and then led
to a kind of Festival style week of you
know daily rehearsals after school with
the professionals with the students with
our um our own Ensemble that's also and
in our own Ensemble um both Musical and
social hanging
out um the day of the show uh very much
trying to make this uh celebration that
was multigenerational and um this is our
elementary age Orchestra getting pumped
before the show um hovered over by a
local politician I'll get back to um any
good uh Community Gathering celebration
needs to involve food we embraced that
philosophy early on uh and in this case
um invited a local Venezuelan restaurant
to provide the uh the
buffet uh and we did this in a community
space that was um a a gym in a community
center but as you can see from the
murals in the background that kind of
celebrated the Civil Rights um history
uh in particular in the black community
and and Rosa Parks and others blazing up
the wall felt fitting for the event um
the politician is our one of our two um
in Rhode Island we only have two uh us
congressmen um again trying to to make
this a sort of widespread Community
celebration uh and then the concert
itself right um performance which I'll
I'll give you a snippet of in a
moment
when when we have done Community
performances in the past there's this
funny and this is where you know it sort
of gets to the heart of the mission the
heart of the work there's this funny
opportunity and divide that happens in
the audiences so um at one level we look
around and we say for a classical music
concert this is unusually diverse we
have um families of our kids we've got
people from all parts of the city who
normally don't come together in any
cultural event and this happens here but
then the question is um what does that
mean or or does it mean anything does it
you know is there in fact a community
formed because uh a Latino mom and a
wealthy white donor are sitting side by
side and join this concert or um is this
a sort of ephemeral moment that if we
make nothing of it so um of course the
answer is
dancing um but the
um uh but I say that lightheartedly but
I think that's one of the critical
question question that I've became
really fascinated by in our community is
you know how do we capitalize on music
bringing together diverse groups of
people but have it be more than a
fleeting moment um a year and a half
later we took the same project to New
York for a um uh a kind of reprised
performance which was a great sort of
uplift moment for the students having
them on the road having them play in a
new context of course um but also kind
of a sense of like how could we do you
know a strategic partnership with folks
in another city to bring about a similar
kind of um diverse Community I'll end
end with a short clip and we can discuss
this more
[Music]
later
don't
[Music]
[Applause]
ET and our last uh panel Tom
cabin to reverse the order
there so that was the window list I
tried to have up okay sorry just go to
the window
beautiful terrific and then you can yeah
right right right thanks I'm learning
I'm
learning
started all right great great we're
getting to the Duke
that's great okay hi
everybody hi um so um another outlier
I'm a composer I'm just saying from the
beginning I'm a composer um my personal
mission is to create new music and uh
for me the process of composing is all
about making choices that make great
musical expression possible but it's not
just what I do I'm also really really
interested in striving other striving to
help others realize their own musical
ideas especially those who have no
musical training at all that's a
specific thing I'm really interested in
what is the song within a person who's
never written a song Never and and and
doesn't have any formal training I'm I'm
really fascinated by that I'm lucky I
get to work across Generations in that
work in my work with Carnegie Hall um I
work with mothers young mothers and
young parents to create lullabi for
their own children we actually have a a
national project around that I get to
work with preschoolers um this week I'm
working with fifth graders writing
graduation anthems played on their
recorders for their Elementary School
graduation that's Friday and I'm
excited
um I also work with teens helping them
to write and produce and perform their
own material um and I have to say that
one of of my favorite forms of music is
coral
music my very first musical experiences
were in the musical
theater but I quickly figured out that
if I wanted to get deeper into music
that the High School chorus was the
place to go so I joined it and I was
there for four years 10 or two and um
and I began singing with others and for
me I think it's one of the most powerful
and rewarding experiences that a human
being can have
alongside growing up in the coral world
I was also growing this expanded notion
of what creating music could be both for
myself and for those with whom I worked
so I began to think about how
choruses might become sources of
inspiration and in turn to become
inspired too and that has led to me to
work on a variety of projects where
choruses are at the center
so for our purposes today I'm good my
Snapshot is a story about a project we
did in the spring of 2014 at Carnegie
Hall called sacred Ellington and this is
the trailer for it 1 2 3
go what you see in the eyes of the young
people is their desire to grow to be
stretched these moments are extremely
important to see something this genuine
on this type of scale is one of the most
powerful things that anybody will
experience ever in their life
Duke Ellington caught me off guard it's
complex but appealing to the ear because
it's jazz in a sacred way Luke Ellington
really knows how to make people feel
that's what's beautiful about it I don't
know it's just I love
it Jazz performance is about people it's
about connecting there's a sense of
community that comes from playing with
jazz he formed bonds with people 250
people all together wow wow dance dance
dance it's incorporating your soul and
how you feel to make the music come to
life when you hear it you're just like I
never even thought that that was
possible you're going to want to move
clap your hands and get up out of your
seat it's going to be an experience to
remember I don't know how to explain
it's just a big deal cuz it's kind of
get H I think it's going to be life
changing for
[Music]
[Applause]
me
okay so you get the idea it's a chorus
of
225 public high school students from New
York City 25 Jazz instrumentalists
professional soloists they rehearse all
year and then in um in March on a Sunday
afternoon at Carnegie Hall in the big
Hall in Stern
Auditorium um
they do the sacred concerts the Sacred
Music of Duke Ellington and it was
amazing they brought the house down it
was a great concert I can't show it to
you because that one's not on film but
it was it was amazing but that wasn't
all sacred Ellington was also about
creating new music inspired by the
Duke's unflagging sense of affirmation
what we did was we asked songwriters and
chers around New York City um what they
could affirm in their own lives and to
try to write a song or some piece from a
deep a place deep within um that that
used the Duke's positive energy that was
the that was the prompt um there were
songwriting workshops at schools so we
had three schools and they actually
created coral pieces I'm not going to
show you one of those but they were cool
too so they wrote them for choruses and
they they they were very Nifty pieces
beautiful pieces um but they were also
songwriting workshops in community
centers and that's the one I'm going to
tell you about um the workshop that I
led was in Harlem on 127th Street in
Linux Avenue in a community center um it
the work that I was doing there involved
10 young people who were on
probation part of their sentence from
the judge was a requirement to take
advantage of the programming designed to
help them hit the reset button and make
their own way they could choose
different things but one of them that
they could choose was a songwriting
Workshop so that came from the judge
thank you judge our Workshop
um uh involved several professional
musicians we actually had a whole
Haitian pop band Led by emilene Michelle
and if you if you follow Haitian pop
music she's she's a star um we also had
two recently graduated singers from the
songs of Solomon inspiration Ensemble
that group is led by Shantel Wright in
New York City it's a great chorus so
these were kids who' graduated out so
they weren't singing with the group
anymore and were're looking for work so
we hired them to be part of this group
group to work with these 10 teenagers to
help them write songs one of the kids
was a 15-year-old boy named
meak despite his initial protest that he
couldn't write a song with our help
slowly he began about a couple weeks in
he he wrote a couplet a couple of lines
and he offered them up in our little
song Circle that we had going I was
thinking about you know different song
circles um mentioned earlier in the day
and um
meak for the first time in a long time
was not shut down by anybody and in fact
emilene Michelle came up to him
afterwards and said you know meak those
two lines I think there's a song
there the next week he came back with
three fully formed verses on his phone
because that's where they write their
songs now these days is on their phone
and he read it to me in a corner of the
room before the workshop started and we
had had a a chat about what his song was
about I set him up with Orson and Victor
those two singers from uh Songs of
Solomon and they helped him chisel it
down till the the um the lines really
made rhythmic sense and a couple of
sessions later he really had the lyric
in shape he wrote The Melody for this
two-line hook um that that you'll see
becomes the refrain of the song and the
song is really about it's a prophecy
it's a prediction of what Meshach wants
his life to be um he he talks about
having been sidelined by his time in the
streets and he wants to resurrect
himself and so the song is living the
life I love so here we were at the end
of 12 weeks now this is December of
2013 and we're in an auditorium much
like this a little bigger School
auditorium and um the music positions
are assembled and um I'll I'll let you
see a little bit of um of
meak see if I can if I can find it here
we
go
yeah okay here we
[Applause]
[Music]
go
yeah yeah
live the
[Music]
life that's what I always
dream the life love living the life I
love the life love in the life I live
never be back never be back be back
never be back never be back in the
street never be back in the streets
living the life love living the life
love the life the life never be back be
back never be back never be back never
be back in the street I remember the day
when I was scrapping to eat Dash the
police guilty of being black in the
streets blacking as sleep dreaming of
being big grind passionately can't wait
this SP a stack on my feet relax on the
beach M away like wax in the heat I'mma
make my life sweet money at my feet but
I never W up back in the streets I will
live the life that I always dream living
the life I
love the
life never be back be back never be back
be back never be back in the street
never be back in the street living the
life for love living the life for
loveing the life loveing the life never
be back never be back never be back
never be back never be back in the
street okay cool so that's meak right
singing his song for their very first
time and I think you can see him sort of
trying to find himself there and I love
that little moment where he drops the
mic cord and then where it comes apart
and then he has to pick up another mic
and and sort of move on and just to say
the words I'll read them for you for the
verse um I I remember the days when I
was scrapping to eat dashing police
guilty of being black in the streets
lacking to sleep dreaming of being big
grind passionately can't wait to spend a
stack on my feet relax on the beach
worries melting away like wax in the
heat I'mma make my life sweet money at
my feet but I'll never wind up back in
the streets so that was um M the first
verse there are three um
and there was there were 10 songs
premiered um at that concert and of
those 10 songs U meak was chosen to be
performed um at Carnegie Hall bringing
together all of the Citywide projects
inspired by Duke Ellington and I'm just
going to show you a little bit here of
again this is um just an archival
recording but here he is now at Carnegie
Hall as you can see he's now got a
trumpet and a saxophone and um still
Emil Michelle still Victor and oron his
backup singers um behind him
[Music]
[Applause]
but people say that doing a bad thing is
wrong I believe that's why I'm writing
this song I
I
[Music]
my
[Applause]
so you know one of the
things um one of the things that I think
is so cool
um
[Applause]
everybody one of the things I think is
so cool about this for mhach was that
that reception and who was out in the
audience it was
chers that was who was cheering him on
the people who'd sung at Carnegie Hall
the week before were now cheering him on
so mesach he got to sing at Carnegie
Hall he sung for the mayor he's taken
this song around but he's also joined a
theater company where he's writing
monologues and scenes and Performing
them as well it doesn't mean he's not
still struggling right mhak still has a
very complicated family that sometimes
creates more
obstacles um than they should he has a
school that is underresourced and does
not have the kinds of programs that
would support his you know interest as
an artist um and it still takes him a
lot of work to get to the places where
he can do his artistic work but he's
figuring it out and he's trying he's now
just turned um 17 years old and um and
we are still working with him um and
it's all in my mind it's all fueled by
creativity by in this case Duke
Ellington but at its source and again
this might be a stretch right because
that doesn't look like Coral
music but I would argue that what's at
the center of this is in fact
Coral music thank
[Applause]
[Music]
you
so this is the point we can um begin to
open this up to each other but also to
you all um here's a radical moment of
stagecraft ready can we make our tables
more like a V so we can see each other
crazy awesome all right now it's a panel
where we actually can see each other too
thank you so um I let me draw out a
couple of points and then uh please feel
free if you've already got comments to
to stand up and make those microphones
look ready for action so that we can
jump right into your comments as well um
one one thing we we drew out in our
discussion with each other was this
question of um otherness
right um if if we're working in in in
populations as musicians that um that
are not not populations are not uh
communities that we come
from what is the work there for us what
is the work there um for the musicians
for for the young people who teaching or
for the students in prisons or things
what is that divide of otherness is is
is that a conflict is that an
opportunity is it both who learns the
most I wonder if um I could just throw
that maybe Mike could jump in there sure
in terms of uh in terms of otherness
between us as the sort of conductor
facilitator of the project that's what I
was thinking yeah although you you deal
with multiple forms of otherness in all
kinds of otherness um I think it's
particularly interesting for me
obviously because I grew up here in the
states and outside DC and now I'm living
in Jerusalem working with Israelis and
Palestinians in Hebrew and Arabic uh and
in English um but there are a number of
things that I think have made it
possible for me to do good work in that
environment and to in many ways there
are lots of obstacles to overcome given
that otherness but in many ways that
otherness also gives me a lot of access
to both communities in an even-handed
way um particularly if I if I came from
or identified specifically with either
the Israeli side or the Palestinian side
or only spoke only spoke Hebrew or only
spoke Arabic or only understood western
music or only understood Arabic music I
wouldn't be able to do the work that I
do in terms of creating a space uh that
really can be inclusive and meet
everyone where they are um and
particularly um in our in our in our
concert tomorrow you'll see that a
repertoire is far from that of a
traditional choir um I think we do one
song that could like from the classical
tradition period um and only with a
chamber choir that comes to specific
extra rehearsals and has more access to
that kind of soundscape because even in
Arabic music there's no concept of
Harmony it's a melodic tradition it's an
improvisatory heterophonic tradition
rather than a harmonic or polyphonic one
so some of the kids in the choir come
and for three years they've been in the
choir and they still have trouble with
the warm-ups but they can improvise
poetry sung poetry in performance and
and no one can do what they do so in
many ways having um access to sort of
both of those uh backgrounds is very
very important both in terms of spoken
language and also in terms of musical
language not even to mention sort of all
the political understanding of uh sort
of both narratives and communities and
and all of those
Els that's so
interesting I hadn't thought of it that
way but so interesting that that you're
not being from either Community gives
you more fluency fluency or fluidity
between the two um um TJ I wonder if you
would talk more about the teaser you
gave us about going to South Korea um
having sort of yearned for that sense of
belonging and whether that happened
there or not and um and how you deal
with this question with International
exchanges of uh of people being from
different communities come sure I think
being adopted this is something that
maybe I've always had an eye
or part of my heart reaching out across
the ocean and thinking that this is
something that I needed to be a part of
and I didn't quite know how and so this
uh maybe was an obvious choice for me to
go into this work and be passionate
about International Exchange but I I
think this concept of otherness is
particularly important for this program
because we have these leaders of our
profession from different countries who
are traveling abroad and uh engaging at
very high levels but I want to say from
firsthand experience it's been this
professional versus amateur comment that
was made earlier I think Anton made it
it's been the experiences with the
community Community with the amateur
with the non-music reader the person
who's just join it for the first time
that have been perhaps the most
impactful and this is something that
reminds us with every exchange with
every program that we put together it's
about the human connections we have and
so this otherness really becomes about
us and so you know for myself being a
child of adoption maybe this is
something that's always been at the
Forefront of my thinking um but I see
this played out time and again with our
Exchange program so s of that contrast
of of otherness versus that sort of more
comma experience that that these musical
opportunities give um eron I wonder if
if there's a a perspective of this in
the prisons that um that that's part of
your experience as as an
educator yeah I mean TJ when you say
that the otherness is about us I think
that's that's a great way of putting it
and that's certainly been our experience
and everyone that we have brought into
the prison who comes from more of a kind
of traditional Arts learning environment
um has said how much they have learned
from being in this environment and from
working with people who are incredibly
creative just maybe don't have the same
resources that we have I mean you see
these images that are and Andre told us
earlier how how the men melt M&M's to
take the paint or the the color from the
M&Ms to make paint I mean it's just
crazy creativity and I think the other
thing that I would say about otherness
is that for as as much as I recognize
that I my experience is not the
experience of most of the people who are
in the prison I also have found
connected connectivity in the community
in ways that have surprised me for
instance uh I also am a conductor for an
organization called the Boston
Children's Chorus which has a mission of
bringing about social change through
music and I thought I knew my students
pretty well I thought I knew their
families pretty well and I was shocked
one day uh after conducting a
performance I turned around and one of
the prison guards they're the
correctional officers but one of those
correctional officers was there and it
turned out that her niece sang in my
choir uh and that was kind of a a
shocking moment to me to realize that
this you know we put people in prison
and we think that they are apart from us
we think that they are other but the
whole system continues to interact with
our own lives in ways that we we can't
even possibly
imagine I think there's a um uh the word
humanization um comes to my mind in a
lot of these stories and um certainly
one of my um sort of intellectual heroes
in in my work is pal Fury um and and
it's like you know in that case through
dialogue through sort of literal
discussion with one another about the
reality we see around us how can we
humanize one another but in a sense uh
the the music and and and actually I've
often struggled in what way is music
problematic when when wanting to sort of
um learn from Fury um because there is
this sort of fixed thing so often called
the repertoire um but these moments
you're you're
discussing um I I think resolve that in
a really interesting way this is very
humanizing to to have an opportunity to
learn from someone else's
creativity uh Tom wonder if there's a
thread here you want to pick up in your
work well I just think it's very very
hard um honestly um I struggle with it
all the time because as you you talk
about Pao FR I mean it's like there's
power is involved right and even even
when I put myself in in these positions
where I'm trying to put um instruments
and and singers and all kinds of people
at the service of somebody else and that
feels in a certain way good but it also
means that we're controlling a lot we're
controlling the par parameters and and
the power does not go away the power
issues don't go away just because you
say here I'm going to help you write a
song and you can have the stage and you
can have the song go how you want and
you can you can do all of those things
but still you're still determining a lot
even by the
assignment and so I feel like you know
check off talked about you know trying
to sort of squeeze the drops of slavery
out of yourself one by one over a
lifetime you know and slavery to what in
a way slavery to to our understanding of
power and class and struggle and it's um
it it I find it immensely challenging
and when Emily brought the thing up I'm
still thinking about Emily's I don't
know if you are but I'm still thinking
about Emily's problem you know she's
just done a fantastic exercise and they
they've done this game and one of them
is feeling like that was a catharsis and
the others are like I wish you'd never
done that and how you deal with that
moment you know that to me that's
another so that's emblematic of of the
struggle that we have all the time in
trying to expand the circles and do the
work it doesn't it doesn't get easier
you learn techniques and you get better
and you can appreciate otherness more
but it doesn't get easier in my
experience so that we have uh a mere 10
minutes left in our time together um and
I want to be sure that if you have
things to contribute to this
conversation or questions that you do um
so let me in the Quaker style let me
leave a moment of silence in case
someone is moveed for a question and if
none of you have come on come on come we
have a lot more we could say come on
come on you have a question someone's
got a question someone has a comment
someone thinks we're crazy come
on uh there now racing okay yeah um I
just wanted to ask do any of you because
our art is so hard to produce you know
quantitative evidence that we're doing
good and I loved what Stephen presented
earlier because that was actually really
helpful um but do you do any of you in
your own program struggle with getting
funding to continue the work that you're
doing is that ever an issue and how how
do you deal with it I know when it did
not but you know specifically with the
projects you do how do you deal with
those challenges so um just before you
leave the microphone entirely um are you
asking uh
specifically how programs like these get
funding or how do you get funding and
then do you ever struggle with with uh
continuing to receive funding over the
long term because it's hard to prove
what you're doing is Su I'm I'm asking
this because it's something I encounter
in uh or at least I when I do work in
South Africa with HIV choirs they have a
very hard time proving that what they're
doing is actually creating change in
their communities and so yeah so there's
a there's an increasing rhetoric around
impact right in philanthropy and let me
see that you can prove that you know a
plus b equals positive change um who
who's feeling this issue the most and
wants to start yeah well I'm happy to
start I mean you have to behind me
though is that big red C from Carnegie
Hall so that means there all this Army
of people behind me raising money but
the issues are the same I think in that
this is not audience building you can't
argue that working in the prison is
audience building right or working with
kids on probation is audience building
it's not right and to try to make that
connection doesn't make sense so what
you really need are great thought
Partners who will help you think about
how to assess the work to provide the
qualitative the the anecdotal the
documentary The you know the evidence
that you need and that there people who
are aware of what the Zeitgeist is
around funding you need thought Partners
to help you think about how you're going
to measure the impact and the good thing
is that along with that I think you can
also learn how to get better that those
evaluators or you know thought Partners
can help you get better at the work and
make the and and actually increase the
impact of the work but it but the one
trap that I see people falling into a
lot is trying to like to answer the why
question and
failing yeah M um I don't know anything
about the financial structure of your
program but is this an issue for you
fundraising um well I'm very grateful in
many ways actually to the the AL alumni
singing community in large part actually
for certainly providing almost entirely
the funding for the course to come come
to this Festival um through a
combination of a number of people who
really believed in this idea and
believed in the ethos of coral music and
group singing creating social change
even when I was here three years ago
before I had done anything before I had
just graduated and I was going to move
to Jerusalem and I was here as sort of a
conductor of this chorus that didn't
exist and um and already had a great
deal of support uh particularly from
Jeff um and from a number of of um
members of the AL alumni chorus and the
alumni chorus Foundation um and so that
I am incredibly grateful not only to
their belief in the power of something
like this but also making things like
this actually possible in a very
tangible way um giving seed funding for
the chorus even before it existed and
now um basically bringing the chorus to
the festival and making all of that
possible so I want to take a moment to
so you're not only um you're not only uh
supported in the abstract but you're
talking to the room that makes your work
possible that's very nice
exactly yay we're the Y alumni chorus
people
[Applause]
yay either of you have a a funding
related response you don't have to you
know as lofty as the acda international
conductors Exchange program sounds it is
um by and large a product of
volunteerism and we are very fortunate
to have like-minded individuals who are
passionate about this but one of our
main challenges or two of them one is
sustainability and the other is
scalability you know we have 28
conductors with the Sweden
exchange how does that really translate
to the other 10,000 acda members and we
have to try and find a way to
communicate that and I could give you
anecdotal evidence of that but really
you know one of the things that we rely
on is the Goodwill and the volunteerism
of those um so this last year Jeff
hosted two of our Swedish conductors
here at y University and they use this
as a hub and so we had them doing hom
stays and we had you know local rotary
clubs providing lunches and so this is
something that I've never been ashamed
to participate in and I I go after it
vigorously um Emily and I haven't spoken
on this subject but let me see if
there's another subject U since we are
low on
time is there a way to operate without
funds now I'm thinking of a failed uh
chorus and it's the a waiter staff of
where I live and all these teenagers
come and happy birthday is an
embarrassment and
and and and and I'm thinking well in um
grade school they don't have money and I
don't know whether you can teach primary
or kindergarten teachers how to be
teachers or whether Cookie Monster could
do a better job um maybe I don't know if
Sesame Street works on music but if we
can you you we need to build the base
the Sunday school's gone pretty much for
teaching music to
these uh at at the first level so the
question is what to do so if uh if your
scenario succeeds we're all out of work
so uh we don't want this to work for
free
um uh it is an interesting question and
I think um more more and more people
worrying about this especially as the
sort of ubiquitous presence presence of
music education in schools um has failed
over the last 40 years right so that um
I think in many Suburban districts that
sort of everyone gets some musical
training still exists but in most urban
districts it's not true anymore um
and um so so going back to this question
of of well it sounds like there's two
questions does it rely on on money and
and is there a way to ensure a kind of
broad access no we know it can we find
ways without money can we find ways
without Mone um no we can't we need
money and we need taxpayers to support
music teachers in schools that's what we
need it doesn't I'm sorry there's no
volunteerism in my opinion and we can
differ about this but I think you need
you need there needs to be support of
Music in schools and we need as you said
to do it all to work with the
preschoolers to work with uh the parents
of the preschoolers to work with
kindergarteners to work with Elementary
we've got to work on all the levels at
once it can't there's no there's no
Silver Bullet in in my
opinions I think they need I think they
they they have some and they need more
support but they we also we all of us in
here right are capable of making our
voice known in terms of the importance
of the Arts and education I think we can
do
it I think we are poised um with a
tremendous opportunity when you rais the
concept of the birthday
song The reason we don't sing it well is
while it is a historical song written by
three
sisters it's really not a very good
song and one of my next projects is to
create a new Liturgy of birthday and
celebration songs nice because we need
them and we need to take advantage of
this opportunity that we have in our
culture which is we sing at Christmas
and at birthdays in public together
spontaneously otherwise we're pretty
much
choked so um stay tuned for a new
birthday album all
[Applause]
right it was my pleasure Howard Goodall
you know composer in uh Great Britain um
spoke at our Minnesota Music convention
about this project that goes on in the
public schools in Great Britain where
they it's the folk song project and they
have they
dedicate uh at least like lunch hour
like half hour 45 minutes every day
where everybody in the school the
teachers the students the janitors the
secretaries going to the gym and sing
these folk songs from out of their
Heritage because they're losing it there
and it's been a wildly successful thing
but it's the whole Community doing it so
that may be one idea um not just
bringing people into a special project
but getting the whole Community doing
that including the adults who would need
to model that for the the
children you know um the we talked
earlier today um about the disconnect
between the formal and the community
between the kind of um uh do dwey talks
about wanting to restore continuity
between art and everyday life right so
this idea is not new that there's a need
for more
participation um that will support every
level of music right that it more people
having an opportunity to get in on a
amateur choir or amateur um Orchestra
means there's more people going to see
those orchestras and and professional
choirs um we we may be up to our last
comment or two but go
ahead uh okay I can do two if you want
um no uh just quickly I have data you're
right happy birthday is a really hard
song to sing I've got I've got lots of
data on um the speaking of the British
government and speaking of funding um
music education um they recently spent
millions of pounds on the singup project
which was run by Graham Welch some of
you may know uh Graham and his work
longitudinal uh across nationally um
introducing singing into the schools to
sort of restore the culture of singing
in Great Britain it was extremely
successful um but it required a it was
an act of parliament literally I mean
they funded it from the government um so
it's kind of an interesting
idea
ni um well inspired by Jeff's um morning
lightning round should we finish with
the lightning round um is there one
piece of advice that each of us would
have for people in the room about the
the challenge of expanding the circle
what what one um piece of advice might
be uh things to consider when people
want want to get more into this work
maybe formerly known as
Outreach um I I would say just to think
about both
practically and musically about meeting
people or meeting whichever sort of
community you're hoping to work with or
um or or impact or whatever you're
whatever you're trying to do with that
Community think about where to meet them
both in terms of sort of even thinking
about like why someone would choose to
join a a group like this certainly in
Jerusalem I have to think a lot about
incentives about actually thinking about
when everyone effectively in both
Israeli and Palestinian societies is
saying that what I'm trying to do is bad
why would somebody want to do something
like this um but also in terms of
musical language also in choice of
repertoire and in choice of style and in
choice of uh pedagogy expectations all
of these all these things
meeting meeting people where they are
rather than thinking again I know this
has also happened a lot today but um
rather than thinking okay here is sort
of the repertoire or like this is like
really the best Coral repertoire and
therefore this is what we're going to
teach um to really think about what kind
of music moves the people that you're
trying to work with already and how to
create new musical spaces if we're
really trying to engage people who
aren't already um um who don't already
have access to to Coral singing or even
to sort of group singing in in any
context um what what kinds of tools do
we have to reach those people in ways
that will actually be interesting or
meaningful uh to them which isn't to say
um particularly as as Molly was saying
earlier today about um even finding this
amazing meaning in uh this sort of
obscure piece by handle even for inner
city kids in Chicago not saying that
that is not possible but might be a
difficult place to
start TJ well I know that I'm speaking
to the initiated but may perhaps this is
something that we need to continue to
advocate for ourselves in a very strong
way there was something recently that
came out about um trying to connect
music to math as being an incorrect way
to do this and and and I certainly agree
with that we we need to learn how to
Advocate we need to continue to do it
locally I mean we we want to think about
otherness we want think about beyond our
borders but unless we have a strong
Community where we are um with those
humans that we interact with this is not
going to be able to take flight um
certainly isn't going to be um uh get
traction I guess I would say
um going into these environments I found
that it's very important to have no
expectations and that means being
willing to reassess and re-evaluate and
question what you're doing and why
you're doing it and be willing to change
because you'll probably need to change
your approach many times so being open
to that is very
important and I guess i' just say if
you're if you want to work in a place um
go visit there spend time work in the
kitchen sit in the lobby talk to people
be there show up for events that are not
about your
chorus and see what's going
on so there there's a theme and I guess
I'll jump on the theme
um in inherent in the work I do is an
attempt to just be there um to set up
this uh chamber Ensemble where we live
and work in this community um but I I
guess this for me goes back to to FY and
to say um how can I approach a teaching
situation as a
learner right and how can I know that I
don't know all I'm going to know after
the experience um and I I I find it
exciting in maybe similar ways um to
what Michael was just saying that it's
also an experience of the repertoire
learning and expanding right that we we
can celebrate and continue to play or
sing some repertoire that we
value um I don't think it's about
throwing out the Canon to do something
new um nor do I think youve you've
suggested that but but at the same time
every era of musical composition grew by
the circumstances of who was there and
who was making music and contributing so
it's both about how do we as
practitioners or
Educators approach a situation as
learners but also how are we stimulating
newness and learning in the in the art
form
itself thank you for your attention and
interest and uh we will see you at the
next one thanks so
[Applause]
[Music]
much
I'm moving you
up
we'll start in a minute if you could
take your
seats
Welcome to our fourth and final panel
crafting
performance Jean batist Bon is Conductor
and professor of art education at the
national Conservatory of St aen in July
2010 he was appointed music director of
the International Academy of coral
singing intera pox he is also artistic
and pedagogic director of the M DEA
acquir school and president of
documenting 21c a nonprofit organization
which produces documentaries that
illuminate musical social projects Lona
Larson one of Sweden's most
distinguished conductors is an
Innovative Coral leader with strong
musical Integrity in 1999 she founded
the vocal Ensemble voes Nord a
prize-winning vocal Ensemble from
Stockholm consisting of 16 singers
Donald Mali is conductor of the crossing
director of coral organizations at
Northwestern University and chorus
Master of the Chicago Bach project
Francisco Nunes is a composer conductor
Visionary leading figure in music
education and the artistic director and
founder of the young people's chorus of
New York City renowned worldwide for its
diversity and artistic
[Applause]
[Music]
Excellence hello everybody I am Jean
batist from France and uh if you want we
will make an experience of musical do
you want to sing with us yes thank you
um the question question
is please try to find in yourself a
word a poetic
word a beautiful word a spiritual
word who
[Music]
can give a part of answer about the
question how the coral practice can
participate participate to change our
life please find in your mind a
beautiful and poetic
word who can give an answer about this
question you can close your eyes if you
want
and now can you whisper the
word your
[Music]
word with
intensity with
spirituality with a very height
spiritual
level and now you can sing improvisation
everybody
[Music]
please
s
[Music]
and
now can you make a loop a loop
[Music]
J
PR
[Music]
you
[Applause]
hello I'm Francisco Nunes very excited
to be here beautiful singing We decided
since it's called crafting performance
we create a performance little out of
the box thank you for working with us
there so in this
panel we've been challenged with the
idea of creating an idea of what to do
next is chorus music really working
today is it hearing so much about it
today new audiences new ways of doing it
all does it really transform Our Lives
if so whose life is being transformed
the composer the conductor the singers
of the audience you know I've been
working now in the coral world even
though I look very young I've been
working in the coral world since for
nearly 30 years you were supposed to
laugh at that moment and it did not work
thank you I in C um I've been working in
the core world for nearly 30 years and
I've seen many changes enough changes to
remain the
same I've watched the industry de sble
recombine and change but
basically very little has changed
there's now greater visibility for chir
as you heard from YouTube and even
SoundCloud but a decrease in Fidelity
because of the limitations of these
platforms is making our listening change
I've seen Coral composers Infuse
complicated rhythms making music sound
even more authentic from the countries
that they're coming from they're adding
sophisticated stacked cords creating
clusters of crunch cords that eventually
resolve While others are writing even
simpler music formula inspired creation
that will be sold to the masses I've
seen a change from recordings of
playlists that were putting together a
favorite pieces from different places to
what's happening composer Centric
recordings concerts are changing too
from a playlist of songs tied together
from a a theme or what the the conductor
likes to put together now we are very
much composer Centric in our
cont it was theorized that at the peak
of 10 television you when you could not
rewind you could not record when you saw
a show it
disappeared of course unless you use the
VHS our attention spans got shorter
because of the commercials so our
children were starting to not pay as
much
attention now with the influx of Netflix
Hulu HBO GO showtime and Time Warner
Cable or what's out here uh
what's out in um Connecticut you guys
Charter you're able to rewind we can
skip through the commercials through
Netflix we don't have to watch
commercials at all we can watch an
entire show for 50 minutes and then get
our food come back and watch six of them
and we have this video binging that's
happening and I'm seeing a difference in
our concert as well so I wonder if we're
getting where we have Marathon concerts
conc that are longer compositions that
are longer this listening bench might
start to take off here you know more
people are singing in choirs chorus
America I've heard acdh y so I want to
bring chorus America in at this point
chorus America has a study that says
more and more people are indeed singing
more and because of that they're
involving more of their friends to come
to
concerts so chorus music is not dead for
those people but I do think we need to
rethink our approach to Performance we
need to look at ways to evolve and be
part of the time for example the first P
prize in 1943 was given to
William
Schuman for stand stand and sing Coral
peace with Orchestra then again in 1946
to Leo solby for another stand and sing
piece with Orchestra so the choir was
very important then not until 2003 was a
peer tog given for Coral piece Opera was
involved so there is singing But since
2003 four composers have won a pish for
actual Coral Works some of them AC
capella all four of these compositions
reth thought the performance they use
Innovative techniques descriptive
writing paired with experimental
ensembles that stretch the listeners
concept of call Art these works are
having a profound and immediate impact
on performers and audiences today the
impact is a result of deliberate choices
being made to craft the
performance it is how is what you want
to say to an audience that's very
important and to whom you say it we have
a saying in our chorus University of
lead club that I conduct you've paid
really good money for this Chorus for
this concert Shea sing very well CU we
are still performing for ourselves in
many many ways so how do we indeed bring
in new audiences at the conclu uh so I
want to say we are all going to share
our experiences and what we do in our
work in different parts of the world and
at the conclusion we're going to do this
a little bit differently I've asked
every presenter when they come up here
they're going to be um responded by one
of the other conductors to their work so
there will be a little dialogue between
the two of them and at the end of the
entire thing we're hoping that you'll be
inspired in some way for some of this
work to go to you we hope our stories
will give you further thought so it's my
pleasure to introduce our first panelist
and our first improvisation a Mr Jean
Baptist
[Applause]
ban
I would like to speak with you about two
experimental concerts the first one is
called Pablo sharp
2 it was played with four compan the
children course choir choir school
called
metri that I am conducting now the
quartet Novo cha trombon double clarinet
the professional choir resonance
contemporan and a percussionist band
called
percussion these percussionists are
absolutely unique they play all over the
world and all of them are person with
mental
disability Down syndrome very low
intellectual IQ Etc and very very high
artistic
potential Pablo sharp to was composed by
Pascal B and program by two very
important Jazz
Festival this creation was composed uh
this cre creation sorry is inspired by
Pablo Picasso he was absolutely
fascinated by the children's creativity
the creative child
s that's that's why the presence of the
color of children voices was natural in
this project the show was a sort of
ccope which mixed instrumental pieces
with texts by Picasso and some of his
friends Max jackob and Paul
Ela the meeting between what we call
handicap and what we commonly call
normality creates a really rich
situation the meaning of this concert
was out of TR additional concept the
presence of down syndrome musicians
requested to question each player of
this project
first the problem was just the fear fear
about differences the fear about Down
syndrome the real handicap was not the
mental disability but the difficulty in
the society which promotes an elit test
and standard standardized Excellence to
approach the issue of
differences the fear disappeared when we
first heard the
percussionist they were in total
artistic fusion and connection with
Picasso's
language fully invested both physically
and
spiritually they showed us the way to
find the right relationship between the
musical people is and in our and our
inner
self secondly from the beginning of the
project and up to the first concert the
investors of the project were were a
little bit little bit uneasy with this
situation for them the question perhaps
the first fear was how to promote and
how to sell a show with Down Syndrome
musician in a professional Festival of
music hard question for them the
question was very hard because there was
also a lot of money at stake finally
that they decided not to consider the
handicap in the communication
strategy they just made a publicity on
the artistic content
Picasso this Choice was in my
opinion a good one because the
experiment
has probably been convincing for people
who otherwise will not have showed up
for these people this change their idea
of what is
Excellence third it is really difficult
to tell with words how big the a
audience reaction was but I am sure that
this concert raises in the mind of a lot
of person new questions about Humanity
the mix of Picasso's language with
percussion is absolutely sincere deeply
artistic without any artificial
postures cause a real
introspection around the issue of the
art
concept and of the art
practice I would like now to speak with
you about a second
project
in July 2013 in Indonesia for the Bal
International choir Festival Professor
Andre de cuadros asked us to invent a
choreographic instrumental and coral
form for the award ceremony of the
competition before the presentation of
the project I would like to say one word
about the cultural context you know that
Asia is absolutely fascinated by the
Western world based on
conception Indonesia is a really
Multicultural and multi- traditional
country and we can
observe that Western model tend to
destroy cultural differences step by
step a lot of young person totally
ignore Indonesian traditional practices
to which they are not directly connected
anymore many are disconn disconnected
from their own Roots we had to compose
in five days a complex menu first
ingredient a young Indonesian choir
composed of a good young
singers
jeans they share very young they had 20
years they have
jeans iPad Rayband and shwing gums
second ingredient a traditional
Orchestra of gaman from
Bali third ingredient two traditional
dancers and two soloist singers who live
in
baliy for ingredient four accidental
musicians Andre and Emily from USA
lucash from Italy and me from France the
topic of the menu the meeting between
Western and Eastern cultur
for that we use Shiva dance teams of
melson Psalms and Balan
teams to compose a menu we use some
notes of the gaman these notes reminded
us about mandelson teams har of
God
and we told these teams to the
percist the Indonesian soloist singers
as for them to us traditional
[Music]
teams the young singers learned the
coreography of Shiva dance with Andre
and
dancers
progressively as all these crosscultural
transfers were put in place the
structure of the show was revealed to
us the public is here the public is
here this is the movement of the
[Music]
choir
IND
are
[Music]
[Applause]
you can you
try
it's difficult I know I know it's really
it's not in your language but it's
interesting
because we we you never hear the sound
it's difficult to make a sound that we
never
hear okay give learn new sounds that I
don't know I want
try it's great when when she and wheni
sing hard of God so we are making a
different kind of music together a
different kind of work sharing ideas
sharing cultures sharing this kind of
this kind of experience becoming closer
to each other people from minahasa
people from Bali to come closer together
right so the main things to concentrate
for tomorrow is are the detail the
detail the last day we gave the concert
in the temple of Art in
[Music]
valy for me it was more than a
concert at a spiritual level it was like
a window open into a cultural space
where each of us was connected to
different Roots Our Roots oer Roots
which without anything being altered
nourished a kind of tree well bred in a
dynamic
ecosystem
[Music]
oh
back
[Music]
you
after the concert young Indonesian
singers were speaking with curiosity and
appetite about traditional music of Bali
it was new for them let's emphasize the
technical challenge which consists of
handling Multicultural elements and the
huge huge Dedication that everyone gave
to practice and understand the language
of of each other the context of the
concert was also really interesting
because the public was absolutely
surprised and for a part of it perhaps a
little bit provoked or even shocked by
this original form it is why I feel that
this experience was in complete
opposition to cult cultural
globalization which commercially
promotes and a destructive and tasteless
conception of word music
this concert was really unique because
each of us was like a tight R Walker on
a wire on the right side the West on the
left the east in the middle the wire the
present time so something that words
cannot
say perhaps we touch something about a
secret dimension in this
concert perhaps the human human being
needed to invent the conception of the
concert to open a secr space to
exchange to
share and to speak what words cannot
say thank
[Applause]
you
well I first want to say uh that it is
really a privilege to be in a room full
of so many people doing such important
work um and so creatively and that's a
great example of that because that is
really very exciting and I also find it
very interesting that um all through the
day we've heard the same themes kind of
emerge not at the at the Forefront of
this of the different talks but kind of
in the midst of them you know these
belonging um things that we cannot say
with words you know that I keep hearing
these phrases over and over again and
it's really it's affirming but it's also
thought-provoking um when I walked out
at lunch um I saw this um rather
eccentric um older gentleman um
and uh he was doing what what appeared
to be his um lunchtime very very fast
walk walk exercise um he was just really
energetically walking down and I sort of
imagined you know and he looked a little
crazy you honestly but he was he was
just kind of you know um by by um sort
of what I'll call normal standards um
and uh I had this whole like vision of
him you know having won the Nobel Prize
a couple of weeks ago and um and and him
being this like sort of you know um
really you know incredibly intelligent
uh person who um can't read social um
cues all that well um
and I started thinking about you know
this this day made me think about um I
wonder where music lies in his life you
know I I wonder where music lies in lots
of different people's lives who I don't
know but I meet them and you've kind of
Wonder because it lies somewhere in
everybody's life um and and so to hear
you talk about people who are
intellectually
challenged uh engaging so thoroughly um
and actually really at the root it
sounds like they were at the root of
that project um uh that percussion
quartet um is is really
U to me kind of all inspiring um and
also really you know my my life doesn't
involve that so I'm very envious to to
view and and and to watch you know these
this this richness
um so if if I had a question in my
response to you um it would
be to add so these are these are these
are these are dangerous topics you know
when we talk
about eccentric people and people who
are intellectually challenged and we you
know I mean we we have this we've
developed this whole vocabulary and we
have to watch ourselves because of those
of us that grew up 30 years ago had a
different set of vocabulary and we're
constantly trying to formulate what is
the appropriate vocabulary to make sure
that our society is as inclusive as
possible so my question to you is for
that percussion
quartet um with their intellectual
challenges what
changes did you see when they engaged in
music I'm just curious to know
that
Chang it's difficult to say that
because uh I don't know what it changed
for them but I know what it changed for
me it's impossible to say what it
changed for them for me it changed
one thing really important in in my way
of
musician it's change that I realized in
this
moment that
uh the music it's a language but you
know everybody know that it's simple to
say that but the concept of language in
music it's really really really um uh
clear when we practice this
experience because the language is not
the word the language is not the visual
things the language is not only uh uh
the writing uh letters the language is
vibration the language it's energy and I
really I realize that really deeply when
I practice this experience
[Applause]
hi I'm going to make it very simple for
me so now it's you guys that are going
to do the work and I want us to
sing this is a piece by a Swedish
composer that died only a few years ago
Anna melness is the name and we will be
singing it in
English first I want us to sing the
melody together after that we will sing
the tenor and base part together so now
you can sit up in your chairs and be
ready to
sing I just saw that that it was
impossible to
see as in water
face answers to
face so the heart of man reflects the
[Music]
man
one more
[Music]
time
just your ears you see
so the
[Music]
face
and now together ladies first and
then
[Music]
might
and here comes the real challenge now I
want you to stand up and
[Music]
sing
thank you
I want you to be my
miror do whatever I
do am I
standing mirror to figure
out
BL
are you going to do it with him and
you're going to sing at the same time so
you will be the one down your and you do
anything he show you be singing at the
same time okay so we start with
Movement we St
[Music]
singing
is
thank
you that was beautiful I like that thank
you very much and now everyone is
awake I it's only I mean it's not even a
week ago it was last
Wednesday I had the privilege of being
the privilege and the real challenge I
have to say of being part of a
project with ELCA which is a program
that runs around the world and I'm sure
many of you have heard about it before
and it runs a little bit different in
different parts of the world and it is
starting I would say in Stockholm right
now and in Stockholm it is used the
system as
integrating ER refugees and
newly come to Sweden people and children
so that they get to to dance and sing
and do soci social projects to learn
Swedish faster and to make a lot of
music
together and this project I I was kind
of involved with it because it was a
project mixed with the Swedish radio
choir which is I have say the absolute
best Choir in Sweden we have and that
was of course very difficult because you
had a fantastic professional h huge
choir and you had
12 kids from many different parts of the
world who only one of them was born in
Sweden but some of them had only been
there for maybe one year and we were
going to make a project together um we
called it a project about friendship so
that that was our theme and in very
little time we build up a a performance
built on both
animation where the kids had been
drawing and then we speeded up the film
so it was artwork in in animation and
the kids had been also you know walking
around in a shopping mall and telling
about the meaning of life to each other
so we made a film with that and then
together with the Swedish radio choir
and my
assignment you could say was also to
introduce music to these kids with they
would not have been introduced to had we
not had this project so I chose this
piece of music which is not major and
minor and which is
very a fantastic piece compos wise I
mean the text is even shown in how how
it is composed right so and we made a
lot of nice exercises with it and then I
had this fantastic little girl she was
nine years old
suana she came from erria and had only
been in Sweden for one year and she was
standing in front of the radio choir and
in front of her friends and doing this
like you did when they were singing and
she was a very shy girl who could hardly
speak I mean her Swedish was very hard
to understand or is very hard to
understand but all of a sudden this was
so much communication because I I mean
all these adults singers they were
totally moved by this little little girl
who was standing and doing all these
movements and they were following him
her and the atmosphere was so thick in
the room that you could cut it and that
was really an
amazing uh moment for me because I had
had to create meetings in very very
limited time and for me that was really
a meeting and I don't think anyone in
the radi choir or suana will ever forget
that so that was really a special moment
for for all of us so we did the speed
version today you you got the speed
version when it comes to my work ER with
VES
n the best way to describe what I do
with Wes notica is please come to the
concert on
Thursday please do because then it will
be easier to understand what we
do
um some years ago we started just by
walking in the room and were
asked does any song
appear and that thought made a whole
performance so sometimes we do not know
anything and I as a com conductor really
do not know what the result will be in
the end because for me it's very
important to have the input of
everyone so there are three main things
that I always consider when working with
bues n one is how do I look up on my
singers how do we look up on our Coral
singers do we look up on them as
reprod reproductive singers so that they
reproduce something that has been made
or or do we look upon them as
co-creating singers which is a little
bit of a difference I would
say in my studying and the way I have
been trained I felt that I was getting a
little bit more and more into a box and
I didn't like it so much so where where
it was more and more that I was using
singers to reproduce something that I as
a conductor had a goal of which can be a
very good thing let me just say that but
for me it is for me it is much more
creative process if the singers are
co-creating the whole
process so we work a lot with uh with
improvisation because improvisation it
is impossible for me to control and I
like that I like to not know the
answers I think it's a very creative way
of
working so that's one thing then also
how do we look on the audience is the
audience there just because they happen
to be in the same room as we when we are
up here building our own
sphere or is are we really creating
something for the audience are they the
main reason for why we stand on
stage I am one of the most naive persons
in the world so many years ago I had the
thought
that if I could just make one be moved
by a concert I did so that that person
might go from the concert and help maybe
an elderly woman over the street so that
she would go home and be extra kind to
her grand grandchildren so that they
will grow up and make the world around
them just a little bit better that was I
mean I do believe that that's the way
our music can make a
difference and so for me the focus on
the audience is very very
important and Just one thought have you
ever thought about why do we do the
Applause in the end for whom do we do
the Applause
is it for our sake is it because oh look
how good we were now and now we are
worth the Applause or is the focus on
the audience
because the audience needs to give
something back for the balance to be
good so it's a very and for me it's very
important to know how the singers think
about that when they stand on stage it's
very important for me to know that where
are are your focus you're not standing
there just to be you know whoa whoa
you're standing there because the
audience have a need to give something
back so that the balance is good because
we are nothing without the
audience so it's very important to think
I think for me it is very important to
think about these things so that was the
singer and the audience and then the
conductor why do we do what we do is it
for our sake it's for the singer sake or
for the audience sake maybe a little bit
of all of it and maybe for some higher
reasons for some of us but there is
this thing I mean as a conductor it's
very important for me as I said to not
be able to control everything because
then creativity will happen
automatically but if you are very
controlling as a conductor you can kill
creat creativity is my opinion and we
need to keep that alive for music to be
good and I truly do believe that this is
not the most beautiful part of a
concert so I always stand behind the
audience to conduct because I often feel
that the conductor is in the way the
conductor is in the way for the
communication that the singers wants
wants to do and also Al in the way for
the experience of what the singers are
giving so I stand behind the audience to
conduct in good days you create a
spiritual kind of feeling in the whole
room when you are standing behind the
audience instead so this about Focus for
the singer for the audience and for the
com conductor is very I mean that is my
how we start when we work we have done
many different projects we are very
happy and proud to be part of the
conducting 21st SE which we have been
from the beginning and this is a
fantastic job that we are very happy to
be part of and we do shows you could say
Coral shows where we use classical music
to make Scenic
performances and we do work for climate
Opera and and different statements you
could
say uh but we only rehearse twice a
month and for that to be possible we
have to do so that we present the music
and then the singers learn it all on
their own H because we have to both make
the music and the staging in this very
very limited time but the good thing is
that the singers think think it's a lot
of fun so I do never I actually never
have to say now you have to go home and
do your homework please you have to do
this you must know this piece by next
time I never do that if somebody did not
do the homework somebody else of the
singers will say but we can't work we
can't do this if you don't do it at home
so I'm very privileged in that way but I
think it is because the singers feel
that they can affect what we doing they
can really have an impact on the work
that we are doing so for me it it is a
lot of fun because we play and we make
crazy stuff and I never know what the
result will be and I kind of like that
so but come to the concert that is the
easiest way
to
[Applause]
describe
[Music]
[Applause]
Jean bapti has asked me to respond
because is English but um it's wonderful
I think it's quite wonderful um uh so I
I improvisation I noticed you also were
off book just now just being
improvisational so when you when you are
when you're working with a new audience
like this what what what do you is the
feeling going through you is it cuz I
know the feeling going through Me Was
Fear um of what to expect um but you
when you're trying to teach others to do
this how do you overcome that feeling
well I was nervous back there but now
when I'm here I have to say it's
curiosity so when I was sitting there
and Sham btis was presenting I was
looking at all of you and I thought wow
what a wonderful bunch of people wonder
how they are doing today and it's
curiosity so so yeah that's
[Applause]
yeah thank you very much um I usually am
off book as well um however I'm not
today I have spoken uh publicly about
four times in the last three months and
um I'm smiling uh about this be uh my
father died two months ago and uh about
a week after that I was speak I was
supposed to give a 25-minute talk at
Northwestern of some conference about uh
programming and uh it sort somehow went
completely off the rails and I wound up
like the culmination was that I
pronounced that it wasn't my
responsibility to teach the Western
Cannon
which as you can imagine didn't go over
all that well with the faculty so um and
then last week I was in Philadelphia and
I was speaking after a contemporary
music concert and the person who was
moderating was very proud of the last
piece which I thought was just really a
piece of crap and um and um and so he
said isn't you know isn't it so exciting
you know this you know what do you think
about this level of progressiveness you
know and and and and I said well
actually all all five pieces of on this
program are incredibly traditional
including the one that was a world
premiere and again you could hear the
whole audience just again so I'm not
going to I'm not going to do that I'm
just I'm just going to read my notes
okay cuz something's going on up here
that I don't quite get
um when Jeff asked me to address uh he I
I asked Jeff what he'd like me to talk
about he said please speak about these
two areas of of my work um the first is
to share some thoughts about
presentation which is in some ways what
we've been talking about uh on this
panel ways in which the crossing and the
choirs at Northwestern have produced
Works while uh reimagining spaces
incorporating other mediums or simply
asking what is a concert in 2015 what is
its purpose um how do we meet that
purpose and I asked that question every
year um the second is to discuss the
role um and here I will quote Jeff
because he has a very particular
sensitive way of putting this the role I
feel new music can plan uh play a part
in so society's examination of larger
non-musical ideas I think he means that
I commission a lot of social or
politically motivated pieces and he
figures I is better for me to talk about
that than anybody else because it's a
dangerous topic um I am going to
apologize sorry I'll just skip that um
this session demonstrates that ensembles
I conduct are certainly not alone in
rethinking what a concert uh Coral
concert is I mean both of these are
beautiful examples of of rethinking what
a coral concert is it's it's amazing I'm
smiling um and the truth is watching a
bunch of people sing is not really the
most interesting thing in the world and
I agree not watching someone's butt
while that happens is even less
interesting so um singers you know do
tend to be uh gregarious physically
expressive and often distracted while
you're conducting them um but um I don't
feel that music or concerts need to be
apologetic about that uh for being
visually static I'm sure most of us in
this room find live music to be
compelling on its own but if we are
going to find our own voice as creators
um or like conductors are
recreators um then we must ask ourselves
in what way does our art reflect our
world that art exists to help Define it
to better understand it to bridge the
gap between our conscious and our
subconscious to Mark and manipulate time
to create spaces in which we recognize
our own emotions in others to provide
recognizable gestures that work on our
memory and ultimately to make a
connection that we all long for and
apparently need we do this through
stories and it is how we tell those
stories that defines us and indeed
defines each concert so because I am
visual and because I recognize how
strong the visual is affected by the
oral uh any any filmgoer knows that uh
my ensembles often incorporate visual
elements and put them in spaces that
invite a certain kind of thought about
the journey The Listener is
experiencing I think it's very important
for example to define whether or not we
intend the space within which the music
is heard uh whether it is designed to be
an extension of the outside a formalized
and ritualized Temple whether it is like
Peter Brook's empty space which we will
temporarily occupy or a space purposely
detached uh from the rest of our lives
in our Productions we tend to avoid
using visuals as
adornments uh I don't like going to
concerts of the vial 4 Seasons and being
subjected
to slides of the Pennsylvania Autumn
hillsides um that is certainly not what
theal music is about um sometimes these
extra musical elements uh and I hate
hate that term but I don't know another
one grew out of practical necessity uh
recently we did a premiere of John
Luther Adams work which we
commissioned uh in Philadelphia's ice
spxs which is a kind of cavernous
industrial Cathedral with an enormous
projection screen of about 100 by 30
feet um the piece is in 14 movements and
even though it is very beautiful and is
about sun moon stars birds and a general
love of the natural world and we'll get
back to the Natural World in a minute it
requires the singers to repeat the same
music for 5 minute intervals at a time
over the course of an hour and it is
completely exhausting um and you have to
take breaks between movements or
eventually the whole thing will just go
in the trash um so we designed an
abstract design to uh play um during the
movements um just a kind of background
visual that is actually based on our
logo although you can't tell that um and
between the movements then flocks of
Starlings emulating what we're sort of
singing about would suddenly appear in
these hu you know enormous enormous
screen coming at you and give us about
20 seconds of something very visual to
follow while we drank water and coughed
um and and just reset um and I'm going
to show that now I think there we go
this is a can we bring the
sorry this
is an example
of of that and I will be very honest
with you this is John Luther Adams music
is very quiet and very very long and
slow and the photographer kept saying to
me I can't get a good you just won't
conduct I can't get anything out of you
so this is my demonstration of a very
very quiet slow passage staged staged
for the photographer um at any rate um
while we are in the uh in the ice box in
Philadelphia I'll share another slide
which is uh music and visuals were
imagined together for Francis White's
the third night which is based on a
fragmented suggested but inconclusive
text her partner James prsh designed a
film for it um neither of these two
elements are really independent and they
need each other to work this is a a
photograph from that piece before we
leave John Luther Adams I'll share
another staging of a work you may have
heard of this is cila the breath of the
world which was premiered at Lincoln
Center last summer and wound up uh being
on the cover of the New York Times there
are 80 musicians in this piece and we
decided to place the singers at the
center of the players and the audience
in the reflecting pool on Hurst Plaza it
was really quite magical and the these
musicians were the lucky ones because it
was very hot in New York and they were
standing in the water uh this is true
also of a fantastic piece of Chris Jonas
who worked with artist Dan Cole on a
project we commissioned called the gulf
Between You and Me based on the Deep
waterer Horizon disaster in It singer
mirrored movements in the slowly
progressing animation of this 40-minute
work with images ranging from the view
from the bridge of the rig to the
beaches that would eventually be
destroyed by that
disaster it's this may not read very
well um but that that's Florida ceiling
and it has some of the text in it and
then the next one no sorry in the light
here you can't really see that but it is
um an animated uh picture of the beach
another practical issue came up when we
did jobby tablet's path of Miracles
which probably most of you know when we
first presented in 2009 I was insisted
that the audience not spend um their
entire times looking at their lap
reading the text and there's a whole lot
of text I felt they would not experience
the movement in the piece nor the
perseverance expressed in job's Journey
uh within and without in that piece um
and they wouldn't do that if they were
just staring at the text so um we
designed super tile projections that
capture the feeling of each of uh the
movements and then you can see the Latin
is in the background and the English is
in the foreground and it really gave a
feeling of the of the piece of the
movement itself and also allowed you to
have a sort of super tile where you
don't have to stare oh I'm sorry I'm
skipped ahead oh now I'm really bad okay
um you guys are you knew that was going
to happen at some point right so um the
last one is just a short picture of lost
objects a bang on a can piece by Michael
Gordon David Lang and Julia wolf which
we just completed at um Northwestern and
that's just um just to give you an idea
of some of the stuff we're doing at
Northwestern another uh super tile
solution that I didn't want people
staring into their lapse all the time or
they wouldn't really experience the
expressiveness of the piece now I
realize that we're running late and I
will move as quickly as we can uh to
briefly discuss social issues in 1940
the Great American playwright William S
San wrote in his introduction to an
addition of his play something with a
soldier quote art and politics must move
Clos together closer together reflection
and action must be equally valid in Good
Men If history is not to take one course
and art another the weakness of art is
that great poems do not inoble Politics
as they certainly should and the trouble
with politics is that they Inspire poets
only to mockery and Scorn we have always
believed that art should be one thing
religion one thing politics one thing
morality one thing and so on this kind
of isolation of entities while
convenient is I believe foolish all
things must come together as one which
is man the functioning of all things
should be to the glory of Living Art is
answerable to politics and politics is
answerable to religion and all are
answerable to man so that when there is
disgrace in life as there is now we are
all guilty this quote has really defined
a large part of my work it has inspired
me daily and I reread it often to remind
myself of my own responsibility I
realize that it is a controversial
subject particularly because political
art often fails to be either political
or art because the bias producing it
destroys the possibility for connection
with the other this is why it is so
important to tell stories in our art we
the artists that comprise the ensembles
I conduct are not averse to following
our Collective bias point of view is
essential to great art and is frankly
lacking from some contemporary musical
performances both interpretively and
culturally this was hinted at earlier in
Anton's uh panel um and in discussions
of of some performances that we hear the
whole notion that we can reach more
people by making things more palatable
is just wrong and the church has proved
that the author sorry the author of an
the author of an interview in a magazine
recently said somebody who interviewed
me recently said that my concerts are
designed to make a statement and to
educate and I objected to both because
because that's not the way I think of
this that's not what San is saying in
fact I am unflinching on this topic I
don't like the idea or I cannot stand
the idea that musicians are Educators
and I don't mean in the education I
don't mean in the Academy I mean as
musicians we are entertainers we attempt
to Define our world so that the listener
can recognize themselves in it and
respond that's what art is the
Crossing's work reflects my own loves
biases and concerns and by default the
artists involved in Embrace this on a
certain level however we are here to
better understand our emotional lives
through the Curious way in which a
combination of vibrations in the air
works on our memories and moves us to
laughter or to tears end of story so how
are we approaching this very quickly
recent commissions have included Ted
Hearn sound from the bench which is
based upon Su the Supreme Court's
citizen United case in which they
established corporate personhood Ted
took excerpts from Jenna osman's poetry
based on the cases leading to to the
citizens united tracing the slow and
sneaky emergence of a person with a
first name like Exxon or
Monsanto he set the words of the choir
in a variety of styles in relief against
two guitars electric guitars and drum
set so no matter how loud the choir
sings The Machine those mechanical
guitars can always play louder the golf
between you and me and that's the golf
between you and me was a three composer
three night work the title comes from my
desire to make a piece one of many now
about the environment which I believe is
the single most important issue of our
time and apparently this now puts me in
strange alliance with the Pope which I'm
very proud of
um so I knew it was going to happen uh
um well I guess actually there's been a
couple of other things that he and I
agree on lately so uh but you can't make
a piece about an oil slick really so we
invited Pierre jerice uh to create a
three-part poem one part for each compos
composer that tells stories about the
people involved in particular the story
of the wife of one of the 11 who died on
the rig Jean Coleman combined this with
the sounds of Fukushima and the sounds
of the traditional Japanese instrument
the show as well as Toshi nakamura's
exotic electronic sound world for one of
the pieces Chris Jonas as we have said
created a multifaceted piece in which
the choir appears in sound layers
throughout both physically and orally
and Gabriel Jackson wrote a work that
conjured rather extraordinary anger and
is shockingly moving as a
result we often do works that reference
the beauty of our natural world and the
increasing distance we are from it in
our human Centric environment the late
and great poet Philip LaVine once said
something like by describing the beauty
of a lake we politicize it because that
lake is for sale just like the sky and
the land and everything else this is why
I am so attracted to the music of Santa
ratet roteta a brilliant
Lan and her soundscapes that reproduce
the sounds of lakes and woods through a
kind of cloud with an underlying
suggestion of tonal gestures we see this
a lot in recent so-called postmodern
Works a quote from music from an earlier
time or a recognizably Renaissance
harmonic gesture that defines and
magnifies the distance we are from those
gestures and indeed from our world I'm
going to skip just a little bit about
another project but if you want to ask
me about it later I'll talk to you about
seven responses which involves uh books
to huda's Yu membran oer and ice and a
baroke band and seven composers writing
new words and it's really crazy and wild
and wonderful I will close with a
reflection on what we are actually doing
when we program and present world peace
is in fact never going to be reached
through music otherwise that would have
happened a thousand years ago and we
wouldn't be constantly identifying new
enemies to give us national identity we
wouldn't be dealing with our national
guilt by invading things and Etc music
plays an astonishing role in our lives
that's why we're here it is apparently
so
integral it it's actually
inexplicable is it not however sorry it
is not truly a universal language
because it is so cultural
love and I just said that word
love is a powerful
force and I am fortunate enough to be
surrounded by love the way I know that
you are in your choirs and in your
families of choirs in the form of
artists all the time with the crossing
Northwestern the Vach project the
different people that I visit we can say
a lot in the stories we
tell um and then and with the manner in
which we present those stories as long
as we are disciplined to remember that
our
job I think is to express our inner
lives as the composer
[Applause]
[Music]
Advocates Donald that was quite
beautiful and those photographs are
wonderful we are basically out of time
but and there's one more presentation
but I want to just take a moment to say
ask you you
using your
singers as a
pathway to reach the
audience and you're using for a better
word political art in some ways with
with with where these composers are
creating a mission-based piece of some
kind that they've chosen to represent
Society is it a job for your singers or
do they get passion as you just did when
they work with
you you know I think that honestly the
music that the crossing does and let's
talk about the crossing right now that's
what I'm I think the music that the
crossing does is so extremely difficult
uh well I mean not always but it's often
so difficult um that it takes a lot of
outside work and you know there's um so
there was a disc I heard a discussion of
Professionals of talking about the
professional I sort of overheard a
discussion of talking about professional
singers earlier and about the whole Shaw
uh you know amateur and professional
thing and I actually don't necessarily
agree with that I think the problem with
professional singers is not that they
don't absolutely love it it's that their
hearts get broken by being in situations
that don't Inspire them um and I've seen
it over and over and over again and you
put them in front of a conductor who
just lets them allows them to feel like
they're participating that they're not
some sort of
you know uh you know slave you know you
know yeah Singing Machine to to to to to
present someone else's Viewpoint and
they they just you know they melt they
just change immediately and so so I you
know I I think that um you have to be
invested in the product you have to be
invested in music new music you have to
be invested in the amount of work that's
involved um oh what I was going to say
is that you know there's you know in an
opera house basically you know nobody
memorizes outside the oper house every
every single minute is paid for and
there's an argument to be made for that
you know um but uh there's an argument
to be made against that as well and so
you can't do the work that the crossing
does on that dime um because there's no
budget in the world that could possibly
do that so I would say that I I have
100% um
inclusion um because we just all love
what we do and and the group is really
you know the group is still very um
Democratic actually actually so uh I
can't I we don't have time to go into
that but at some other point well that's
wonderful to hear um because it brings
out the whole day about do we love music
as chorus um there's one more
presentation it's
4:30 would you give me five minutes to
do one more piece you're very I will
keep I will keep it short
um what is exactly the idea of crafting
performance for New York City it's
interesting we use the word
excellence today we use the word
Outreach togetherness
otherness we are creating silos of
people that
move from Community to community to
present their fragmented worlds and
these
fragmentations are moving more rapidly
than they did 15 years ago 15 years ago
they was stagnant more than 15 years ago
thousands of years this was my choir
this was my identity I will sing for me
I will sing for you do not invite others
membership only I will pay to sing to
keep others
out the membership was
restricted with that now something
amazing is
happening this conference we are here we
we are the
amazings we really are our silos are
moving there's a small torado of energy
and musical form that is allowing us to
come together and
bounce and I think the bouncing is
coming quicker and eventually we're
going to snap together and that's when I
think extraordinary change is going to
definitely happen and it's happening
already we're H but can it happen happen
in a coral
world in the word Outreach I love that
we don't use it I love the idea of
bringing together and Excellence is the
key point if you have you want the best
you want the best car the best house the
best other person you can buy it why not
you worked very hard it's
yours if you don't have you accept you
have no other choice you will deal with
a bad teacher a bad conductor bad music
because that's what you have imagine
bringing those to Worlds together
there's only one way to do it
Excellence Excellence will attract the
best and then exence can then move and
get the other and when you bring those
two extremities together you will have
something that's different the silos
come together and music becomes
something for the community of people
that are not supposed to be
there in my opinion it's much easier for
me to go to Washington hi and start a
choir they'll come I can go to holic
choir they'll come there's no one else
doing it but let me go to the oper e
side and get young girls going to
private schools to come together I
better prove that I have something they
don't have and now I'm going to convince
them to sing with a different class of
people Dominican Republic the upper
class and the servant class singing
together very difficult immigrants in
Europe singing with citizens one of the
most difficult things happening right
now in Europe how do we bring those two
classes together those silos we can
continue to sing for each other and as I
said the movement is
great Excellence brought us to the
presidents when we s for 911 and I was
able to bring the
extremes together proudly and they love
each other they support each other and
they listen to each other the word that
I heard over here sung at the very top
listen because that's all we want to do
is listen you want desperately to change
the world you wouldn't be here if you
did not want to change the world and you
want to use the one thing you love more
than anything else oh besides your wife
and your
children music cuz you know what it did
for you these children want it so badly
but they don't want want crappy music
they want Amazing Music just because
you're poor doesn't mean you have to be
bad Trent glory is a program that we
created I created in 2001 to bring choir
the composers that never wrote for this
population before children so now we
went from getting all these composers
right to having an entire Spotlight
entire evening of their music and then
beyond giving a 2hour presentation of
one one composer's music adding lighting
and all kinds of visuals behind it I'm
going to go very quickly here are the
children in Japan singing and moving and
dancing using movement to entice them on
a piece that every Middle School par
[Music]
sings
[Applause]
[Music]
so that has to
be something they can live with and the
audience is completely freaked out at
this point because children are
screaming on stage but that was that was
then they come in and they do other kind
to cut through this and then we can get
the idea of bringing
3,500 children together in a coner
conducted last week at the credential
Center children are that desperate
they're willing to come together this
coner is being replicated again next
year five times we expect 8,000 children
in each coner it's called Young Voices
America and the music is everything
Billy Joel's band is basically he's
playing with them and they're sing
everything from living on the prayer to
Matilda to um classical
music children want excellence in what
they do here's a piece where we
incorporate the audience in the work
where they surround us where we were
celebrating Terry Riley's 80th birthday
Terry Riley is writing for children you
know with a jack
quartet they believe in this so the idea
of creating this it comes from exence
remember who's singing kids that can't
can't afford a token metro card I always
use my age a Metro carard to get home
with hedge fun
kids here they are singing a uh with a
dance company leaving our complete genre
of coral music going to the dance World
Ste patronal company and create we had
150 children surround the entire block
singing as the orst coming in and then
we walked in
singing the last thing I will leave with
you is that the children desperately
want to be great audience
and if you can get composures to write
for them in a very wonderful way
extended
works we will bring Excellence to every
type of child that's out there but we
have to educate our conductors our
audiences to respect young people to
respect all kinds of people to come
together on a journey of Excellence to
bring Rich poor using movement using
video using dance but most importantly
using coral music this is a one minute
film and I'll leave it with
[Music]
us children leading adults leading Coral
music at the highest
level at the next wave Festival of
[Music]
back
music of around the
[Music]
world and that's it for me um I want to
say thank you to our panel Lana you're
supposed to respond to me but I'm afraid
this of these people you're
great uh thank you very
[Music]
[Applause]
much
and let me just say thank you not only
to Donald Lona Jean Baptist and
Francisco but to all of our presenters
throughout the day uh it's been very
thought-provoking I think each each
individual has come at this question not
of whether singing makes a difference
but how singing makes a difference and
what we can do about that uh in deeply
personal ways I have learned so much uh
it's been a wonderful conversation and I
I trust that it's a conversation that
will continue not only throughout the
rest of this week and this Festival but
much more importantly uh Beyond this
festival and thanks to all of you for
being such an engaging audience and
thank you Jeffy for putting this whole
thing
[Applause]
together
it's